que dans le cas du confinement il ya
plus cet entourage et tout se fait à
distance ce qui fait qu'il est très
difficile de repérer par téléphone par
visiophone ces situations et notre
inquiétude elles portent plutôt sur ce
que nous voyons pas la partie immergée
de l'iceberg en fait parce que les très
difficile pour les enfants malgré tout
d'après eux mêmes et dans ce cas là on
n'entend rien ça se fait totalement dans
le silence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur la télé
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités tenues toujours à bonne
distance et nos reporters l'actualité
toujours dominé par la crise du
coronavirus en france et la phase 2 du
déconfinement l'amérique qui s'embrase
près la crise sanitaire les crises
sociales pillage heures couvre-feu dans
plusieurs dizaines de villes la nuit
dernière et garde nationale déployé une
semaine de violences à la suite de la
mort de l'afro américain john jeu flou
et de lundi dernier lors d'une
intervention policière
l'audience du policier incriminé est
reporté
retour en classe des lycées enfin de la
règle des 100 km réouverture des
restaurants en zone verte et des
terrasses en zone orange
j - avant la deuxième étape du
déconfinement en france c'est également
demain midi que l'application
controversé stop qu'ovide doit être
disponible
[Musique]
une semaine après la mort de djordje
floyd un afro américain décédé au cours
d'une interpellation policière
plusieurs manifestations envieraient aux
émeutes aux états unis pour une sixième
nuit de violences scènes de pillage et
d'affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre couvre-feu dans une quarantaine
de villes du pays
retour sur les émeutes en images avec
claire nico la maison blanche plongé
dans le noir est attaquée par des
manifestants
le symbole du pouvoir américain a
violemment été pris à partie cette nuit
à washington donald trump a même été mis
à l'abri quelques heures dans un bunker
souterrain une réponse probable des
manifestants aux propos tenus samedi par
le président américain
il avait menacé les émeutiers si
l'approché de la maison blanche il
n'hésiterait pas à lâcher je cite ces
chiens les plus méchants et à utiliser
les armes les plus inquiétantes des
menaces loin de calmer les
protestataires de nombreux pillages et
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
ont été observées cette nuit dans le
reste du pays
et ce malgré le couvre-feu imposé dans
plusieurs grandes villes américaines
treize mille soldats sont actuellement
mobilisées et puis des scènes
quotidiennes sur réel
commis hier à minneapolis
un camion citerne a forcé le passage
fonçant dans les manifestants
heureusement il n'y aura aucun blessé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à santa monica en californie les forces
de l'ordre ont arrêté plusieurs
manifestants des arrestations
souvent sans distinction des métiers
mais aussi de simples civils
la clyde matters la vie des noirs compte
c'est ce qu'on a encore une fois martelé
les foules de protestataires
les afro américains ne représentent que
13% de la population des états unis ils
ont pourtant trois fois plus de chances
de se faire arrêter par la police
et ça dure depuis bien trop longtemps et
il faut y mettre fin
il y en a assez nous sommes des êtres
humains nous sommes tous pareils nous
devons être traités de la même manière
pas pour une différence de couleur de
classe de race ou de croyances nous
sommes des personnes et nous devons être
traités de la même manière je suis
fatigué c'est un point de basculement je
l'espère c'est quelque chose qui s'est
produit sur plusieurs années mais la
mort de jack floyd a je pense accentuer
la rage la colère que ressentent les
noirs
[Musique]
je suppose que le simple fait de voir le
policier assassiné sur son cou avec son
genou sur la nuque
pendant huit minutes c'était un point de
basculement extrême alors j'espère que
le changement viendra une confrontation
entre policiers et manifestants qui ne
faiblit pourtant pas depuis
l'arrestation du policier accusé du
meurtre de john floyd en six jours plus
de 4000 personnes ont été arrêtées aux
états unis et autres réactions sur les
réseaux sociaux cette fois donald trump
qui dénoncent ces violences dans le
viseur du président américain je cite
les gauchistes radicaux et son rival
démocrate dans la course à la maison
blanche d'obama
soyez ferme avec les maires et les
gouverneurs démocrates
ces gens sont des anarchistes un peu les
nôtres garde nationale maintenant le
monde vous regarde et se moque de geôle
endormi est ce cela que l'amérique veut
non loi et ordre à philadelphie
maintenant ils pillent les magasins
appelée notre grande garde nationale
comme ils l'ont fait enfin merci le
président trump hier soir à minneapolis
c'est cela que les actes envol avec deux
l'endormi tous les démocrates
les médias partiaux font tout ce qui est
en leur pouvoir pour fomenter la haine
et l'anarchie tant que tout le monde
comprend ce qu'il font qu'ils sont de
fausses informations est vraiment de
mauvaises personnes avec un programme
malade nous pouvons facilement les
contourner jusqu'à la grandeur et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
new york avec caleb maupin correspondant
de rtl états unis c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir calais maupin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france tout
d'abord quelles sont les derniers
développements nouvelle nuit d'émeutes à
craindre aux états unis dans plusieurs
villes aux ce qui se passe dans le pays
cela oui c'est historique
nous avons vu des bâtiments temps
washington proche de la maison blanche
qui ont été incendiés dans presque
toutes les grandes villes les gens
descendent dans la rue il y à des
affrontements entre les manifestants et
les autorités
c'est une crise nationale c'est elle que
les stations n'ont jamais vu certaines
personnes comparé cela avec après ce qui
s'est passé après la mort de john martin
king junior
nous avons entendu des rapports selon
lesquels des manifestants ont été visés
par des tirs à dans plusieurs villes
mais on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de morts
2 policiers
le bilan humain combien de personnes
sont mortes les médias traditionnels aux
états unis ne remplissent pas leur rôle
il était mort des manifestants sont
morts et leurs médias n'ont pas on se
comprend se concentre plutôt sur
l'idéologie
les médias de gauche parle de racisme en
nombre allez quoi ton bras de
l'antifascisme et d'autres jeunes
artistes mais on ne parle pas de
personnes qui sont mortes il ya des vies
américaines ou perdu et pourtant les
médias ne s'y intéressent pas
aujourd'hui quel est votre regard
justement sur cette crise vous dites
légères les états unis n'ont quasi
jamais connu ça la faute à quoi la crise
sanitaire
est venue s'ajouter à la crise sociale
très important nous avons eu les
couilles des petits emplois aux etats
unis beaucoup d'américains jeunes
notamment et les afro américains n'ont
pas un emploi régulier
ils ont des petits jobs des petits
emplois
je travaille pour couvert aux poteaux
liberté oui non pas des contrats à long
terme de travail quand ils le peuvent
on n'a pas de travail et beaucoup ne
sont pas comptés dans les statistiques
du chômage
ils sont cons ces choses et de faire
travailler ils s'inquiètent pour la
facture voilà cette vidéo vraiment
horrible où le voiture tu flottes se
faire accuser dans la rue est
effectivement temps à faire le point de
munitions quand c'est l'explosion dont
jean mon travail soit conseil chez nous
et ont filmé les gens sont en colère
qu'on atteint le point d'ébullition et
se retrouve à quelque chose de nouveau
et beaucoup de vent c'est un peu une
institution ce passionné que normalement
les défunts du dossier de police ont
également été conciliant car tout le
monde c est qu on est vraiment au dessus
de la barre de plus qui pourrait se
poser normalement alors quels que soient
leur ton conciliant effectivement les
bars et de poubara exposés n'ont jamais
entendu parler des notes
braskem ou dans le camp des petits
partout dans le coup ce sont des émeutes
au niveau national comme jamais
auparavant c'est dans toutes les régions
c'est vraiment de tous les côtés vu de
l'extérieur
donald trump lui semble en tout cas
c'est ce que nous disent dans les médias
ici en france notamment semble attiser
le feu avec des tweets incendiaires de
notre âme qui répondait de façon
sécuritaire qu'elle est justement la
vision de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
de cette politique de donald trump à ce
qu'il lé jugement du juge et elle est
sévèrement jugée par dont effectivement
largement critiqué cette politique
lorsque le donnait à twitter dès qu'ils
commenceront les pillages nous
commençons à tirer celle ci s'était
beaucoup de colère cela n'avait pas du
tout calmé la situation s'étant fait une
aggravation cela détériore encore la
situation
parce que là je suis anti femmes soient
considérés comme une organisation
terroriste
nous avons effectivement cette
organisation qui sont les antilles fin
de l'année contre l'extrême droite où le
nationalisme manifestent contre la
police et auprès de gouvernement raciste
comme ce n'est pas natif heures qui est
en jeu c'est pourtant deux approches
prétend qu'il s'agirait tue-le que tous
ces manifestants sont payés par ribeiro
est correctement dans je reviens sur
demande
werner de reprendre le contrôle de la
situation de la doline et qu'est ce que
cela veut dire
bien sûr extrêmement effrayante beaucoup
de personnes soutiennent les
manifestants mélange de nanterre plus
pacifiques auraient été les plages et
les incendies rumeurs disant qu'il y
aurait des agents producteurs et qui ne
saurait pas y faire mais plutôt dos aux
personnes affectées qui serait de
conserver la situation et de justifier
une répression très forte
beaucoup de voies très différentes les
médias traditionnels se concentre
uniquement sur ses indices cours d eau
logist les faits on les oublie mise de
côté
merci en tout cas qu'elle est maman pas
en correspondront verte et aux
etats-unis nous d'avoir apporté ce point
de vue sur la situation et la
mobilisation qui dépasse désormais les
frontières américaines plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont ainsi défilé
hier à londres berlin ou encore toronto
retour en images sur ces rassemblements
il
nous voyons depuis des centaines
d'années que les noirs et les gens de
couleur sont absolument maltraités et
tués dans les rues et ça ne fait
qu'empirer
nous en avons assez et s'ils ne veulent
pas écouter dans l'encrier de plus en
plus fort nous n'allons pas arrêter tant
que quelque chose ne sera pas fait vous
nous avons assez ces gens en ont assez
les temps de faire quelques changements
[Applaudissements]
ils vont me tuer ils vont me tuer je ne
peux pas respirer
je ne peux pas respirer s'il vous plaît
monsieur s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je ne peux pas respirer
je promets que les futurs bébés noirs ne
mourront pas parce que je n'en ai pas
fait assez
parce que j'ai passé plus de temps à
pleurer à me plaindre et à poster que je
n'ai fait de vraies actions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tél
1 depuis les années 60 les mairies qui
avait connu des mouvements de
protestation en réaction aux inégalités
aux violences raciales mais peut-on dire
pour autant qu'il y à un racisme
endémique aux états unis pour en parler
nous sommes avec christopher mesnooh
avocat aux barreaux de paris et de new
york américain installé en france
bonsoir à vous christopher mesnooh à ses
côtés pour en parler olivier py ton
avocat cette fois ci au barreau de
washington à l'envers un français
installé aux états unis bonsoir à vous
également olivier quittons merci d'être
avec nous alors c'est le retour des
vieux fantômes où les fantômes ne sont
finalement jamais parti il se reviennent
plus effrayant que jamais selon vous une
gaine et de christophe ernesto à
commencer par vous écoutez j'ai
effectivement le triste sentiment que
les images qu'on voit depuis une semaine
sont à peu près les mêmes que j'ai vu
quand j'étais enfant
c'est pas pour autant qu'on peut pas
dire qu'on a progressé ce ces questions
mais rester régulièrement on revient
toujours et ses problèmes de brutalité
policière des émeutes qui suivent et des
innocents qui sont tués
donc effectivement il ya un côté assez
troublant à ces dernières histoires
analyse oui il ya un phénomène ont démis
de d'émeutes d'émeutes urbaines aux
états unis il y en a eu 14 au cours de
ces vingt dernières années donc c'est un
phénomène effectivement récurrents ce
qui est ce qui est intéressant de mon
point de vue à l'occasion de cette de
ces émeutes là c'est que on a une
juxtaposition du moins une convergence
entre la communauté afro-américaine qui
se sent à juste titre souvent martyrisé
mal traitées avec des taux de mortalité
policière extrêmement élevé par rapport
à la population et
une population blanche plutôt jeune
urbaine à s'est radicalisée et militante
et je pense que l'une des raisons qui
expliquent cette convergence c'est que
peut-être que cette fois ci parlant des
volants des violences policières les
gens ont réagi en se disant bascou là ça
pourrait être moi
alors que dans les émeutes précédente ce
n'était pas forcément le cas et c'était
je pense en particulier aux émeutes de
baltimore qui ont lieu en 2017 c'était
très circonscrit aux communautés il n'y
avait pas de 2,2 de trans courants qui
se mettait en place
là c'est le cas je pense que les gens
ont peur qu'il y a un besoin de lutter
contre ce qu'on appelle l'immunité
qualifiée de la police qui fait que les
gens se sentent potentiellement en
danger et pas simplement les noirs mais
je dirais un petit peu tout le monde aux
états unis après sa femme et ce non
justement
michael jordan est sorti de sa réserve
je suis du côté de ceux qui dénoncent le
racisme on racines et et la violence
envers les personnes de couleur dans
notre pays nous en avons assez mais quel
genre d'homme qui est pas vraiment connu
pour parler politique on lui a souvent
reproché d'ailleurs dans sa carrière
selon vous le racisme est il vraiment
ancré dans la société américaine
il est effectivement ancré dans une
partie où j'ai une partie de la
population américaine
après la question c'est quelle est
l'étendue de ce racisme
je pense que personne ne peut répondre à
la question entre ceux qui disent que le
racisme n'a pas vraiment disparu depuis
50 ans et ceux qui disent qu'il n'existe
plus de racisme officiel
c'est clair que la vérité se situe
quelque part entre les deux on a fait du
progrès il est vrai en revanche qu'il ya
des gens comme ce policier monsieur
chauvine effectivement qui se comporte
comme comment voyez il y à 60 ans dans
le sud du pays
et c'est effectivement étonnant pour
beaucoup d'entre nous après toutes ces
histoires sanglantes et sans pitié de
voir effectivement on ne ramène 50 ans
en arrière
c'est très troublant olivier python
comment vous vous l'expliquer on
rappelle quand même que les états unis
ont élu un président noir y en a
peu de temps comment vous expliquer
justement ce diagnostic que vient de
faire christopher mesnooh
christopher a complètement raison c'est
à dire que la vérité probablement entre
les deux je pense que la société
américaine a évolué dans le bon sens
les dernières émeutes qui ont fait
énormément de morts c'était les émeutes
de los angeles en 1992 il ya eu entre 50
et 55 morts
là actuellement mise à part évidemment
le malheureux de georges floyd celui qui
a été étouffée il n'y a pas de mort
encore alors qu'il ya des scènes
d'émeutes dans quasiment tout le pays
avec 250 villes qui sont actuellement
sous couvre-feu
donc il ya un progrès je dirais dans la
façon d'appréhender le la problématique
des émeutes et de la violence aux états
unis pardonnez mon livre qui tombe est
ce qu'on peut en être sûr justement du
fait qu'il n'y ait pas de mort ou est-ce
qu'il se pourrait que les médias tout
simplement n'en fasse pas écho je pense
qu'avec le l'aîné d'une part la la la
la prévalence des réseaux sociaux
absolument partout et deuxièmement le
fait que je pense que le moindre le
moindre fait dans un sens comme dans
l'autre serait extrapolés au maximum je
crois qu'on peut dire a priori
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas eu de mort
pour l'instant dans les émeutes
ça veut pas dire qu'on n'aura pas mais
ça veut dire que pour l'instant il y en
a il y en a pas en tout cas il y en a
pas de comptabiliser et pour aller pour
aller un petit peu plus loin ce qui est
très intéressant ces émeutes c'est qu'on
a on a un slogan à cannes brief donc je
ne peux plus respirer vous je ne peux
pas respirer
on a on a une gestuelle qui est le genou
à terre et on a une situation un
environnement politique on ne pas
rappeler qu'on est en élection
présidentielle mais également économique
sur lequel il faudrait revenir où on a
la population américaine qui est passé
en deux mois de 3 % à 20 % de chômeurs
26 millions de personnes qui ne sont pas
assurés sociaux
enfin je veux dire on a une explosion de
la delà de la précarité économique
tout ça crée un climat extrêmement
explosif et dans ce climat extrêmement
explosif et c'est ce que je disais au
début on a pas pour l'instant de mort on
a que des dégâts matériels extrêmement
important et on a un énorme clivages
mais on a pas de morts dont pour répond
clairement à votre question je serais
plutôt optimiste il ya quand même un
progrès dans la société américaine je
trouve christopher mesnooh
c'est vrai que nous voilà de france on
voit sur les réseaux sociaux des des
camions foncé dans la foule
vous partagez ce diagnostic plutôt voilà
optimiste d'olivier python il n'y a pas
de morts et on appréhende mieux
aujourd'hui ses mouvements aux états
unis vous êtes d'accord
écoutez un triangle infernal qui est en
train de s'installer au pays entre les
séquelles du clown varus la casse
économique qui est monstrueuse avec les
carreaux millions de chômeurs produit au
moins de deux mois deux mois et demi et
maintenant c'est histoire absolument
incendiaires et avec la proche de l'été
non je
je suis optimiste à long terme sur mon
pays je suis plutôt pessimiste à court à
moyen terme
on a un analyste en france françois
durpaire qui disait plus qu'une émeute
c'est un acte de révolution olivier
pitras ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse vous nous parler
évidemment de cette crise économique
presque sans précédent enfin avec des
précédents mais quand même très très
grave
voilà c'est problèmes de racisme ou
est-ce qu'on est là face à un acte de
révolution une certaine partie du pays
veut justement le changer alors j'adore
j'adore écouter les commentaires mon ami
françois durpaire mais une fois n'est
pas coutume je ne serais pas d'accord
avec lui
non on est on est face à une on est face
à une conjonction des révoltes par la
peur c'est par la peur et la précarité
et la peur d'une part parce que les gens
se disent les violences policières
peuvent me touche et moi je sois un
homme que je sois une femme je sois
blanc que je sois noir je peux me faire
à un moment je peux me retrouver dans la
situation d'un d'orge floyd et en mourir
je pense que les gens en ont marre
effectivement de cette forme d'impunité
policière qui dépasse le cadre du
racisme parce que le racisme il va
falloir le prouver et celle enquête qui
déterminera si des règles chauvine qui
est quand même qui en est déjà à dix
huit blâme
c'est un personnage tout à fait
particulier de la police de mes abdos
minneapolis s'il a agi parce que son
interlocuteur était noir sont suspects
étaient noirs ou parce qu'il l'aurait
fait avec d'autres mais je crois qu'on
est face à cette révolte qui est chauffé
à blanc et christopher a parfaitement
raison par une sorte de triptyque c'est
à dire à la fois politique et économique
mais on n'est pas dans une révolution on
est on est dans quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre à mon avis de la peur il ya une
revendication qui est une revendication
presque émotionnel de l'ordre du du
pathos mais qui ne débouchent pas sur un
discours politique autre que nous on
aura six et encore une fois sur le terme
de racisme je vais mettre quelques 10
mai même si c'est compliqué pour
l'instant on sait qu'un policier a tué
un homme
c'est un policier ultra violent on ne
sait pas s'il a tué pour des raisons
raciales ou simplement parce qu'ils
étaient intrinsèquement
yoland et surtout parce qu'ils pensaient
qu'il était totalement en phase
d'immunité et d'impunité dont justement
pardonnez-moi olivier python cette
impunité est ce que elle n'est pas un
petit peu attisé tout de même par donald
trump qui a par ses tweets appel à
davantage de violence et pas
l'apaisement quel est votre point de vue
alors effectivement au triangle infernal
où qu elles viennent de me référer
il faut rajouter quand même la
personnalité tout particulier du
président trempe et je dirais qu'avec la
proche de la présidentielle en novembre
de cette année mais se trompe a
peut-être une carte à jouer qui est
contre intuitif
je rappelle qu'au début d'année avec un
taux de chômage à 3 5%
beaucoup de personnes dont des
démocrates prenaient pour acquis que
cette étrange qui allait l'emporter en
avant après on a eu sceptre gestion
assez dubitative de la crise du virus
avec son ami mort auquel olivier bien de
se référer ça c'est une catastrophe qui
a fait effectivement comme infléchir
sens inverse alors maintenant on a des
situations qui sont deux autres
contrôles alors ou bien le calme revient
et d'être en regardant à nouveau jeu 30
dans les critiques ou bien sa commune
commence arrive control et monsieur
trempe aura une carte très forte à jouer
c'est de la sécurité merci à tous les
deux merci christopher mesnooh également
olivier python d'avoir un été avec nous
pour décrypter cette situation
dramatique aujourd'hui aux états unis
est justement le chef de l'onu a appelé
il ya quelques instants à enquêter je
cite sur ces violences policières merci
à tous les deux restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous prendrons des
nouvelles
de jean luc reitzer le premier député
atteint du coronavirus qui a été
hospitalisé durant deux mois et demi à
l'hôpital de mulhouse il dit lui-même
être un miraculé il nous racontera tout
ça et puis nous reviendrons sur la phase
ii du déconfinement en france et pour
demain avec notamment la réouverture des
restaurants en zone verte et des
terrasses en zone orange
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas des féminicides
aujourd'hui en france les cours et les
violences existait avant le confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre l'état turler
d'eau de féminicide a plus que je dis
pas doublé mais bien monté forcément on
n'a pas encore tous les chiffres
officiels c'est très difficile gros
n'est jamais d amélie roy a finalement
c'est le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il y en eût clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément dans les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux papes à 3 ici on
écoute ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait trop souvent le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grands défis face
auxquels nous sommes aimés en
particulier le défi québec et ses
conséquences et notamment une pandémie
là c'est la première mêlée qui finit en
avoir d'eau il faut qu'ils aient une
prise de conscience collective vraiment
[Musique]
parce que c'est la question du jour
dans quel monde on a envie de vivre il
faut couche entre le terrain que c'est
la seule façon de proposer une
alternative
je pense en réalité qu on va de plus en
plus à l'est vers le télétravail au
salon au doxa du 1er au 13 avril à 2020
83% des entreprises avaient entre 10 %
et plus de 80% de leurs collaborateurs
en télétravail ya une fantastique
opportunité et on a utilisé pour sa
insolites etc et la visioconférence
il ya infiniment plus efficace le
numérique est il le grand gagnant de la
crise du coffee de 19 c sur que facebook
et google ainsi qu amazon qui d'un point
de vue politique a tout révolutionné
sont pour l'instant les grands gagnants
de cette branche nos libertés sont les
grandes perdantes c'est l'application
d'un
mais c'est l'application d'un modèle qui
n'est pas le nôtre est le problème il
vient de là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 bonsoir à tous merci nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france alors
que la phase 2 du déconfinement est
lancée demain le bilan du coronavirus
dans l'hexagone le nombre de personnes
en réanimation continue sa baisse selon
les chiffres de la direction générale de
la santé ce soir en compte 31 nouveaux
décès à l'hôpital en 24 heures au total
28 mille huit cent trente trois
personnes sont mortes depuis le début de
l'épidémie
et puis nouvelles annonces du ministère
de la santé les ehpad pourront rouvrir
les visites à plus de deux personnes à
la fois et aux mineurs dès vendredi
quant aux personnes sorties gehrig
l'hôpital elles sont au nombre de 68
1355 parmi elles le député l ère du haut
rhin qui avait été on s'en souvient l'un
des premiers du palais bourbon à être
atteint par le coronavirus selon luc
reitzer est aujourd'hui rentré chez lui
après plus de deux mois à l'hôpital
bonsoir jean luc reitzer vous êtes en
direct les cons par téléphone des red
fierté france merci d'être avec nous on
le disait vous avez été le premier
parlementaire avoir été touché par le
kobe première question comment
allez-vous leur eu un mal possible quand
on a passé effectivement deux mois et
demi à l'hôpital avec quatre semaines de
coma profond
quand on a dû réapprendre tous les
gestes de la vie quand on a perdu
quelques vins qu'il use
lorsque l'on se réveille après ce commun
et qu'on arrive au bout de deux mois de
nouveau à pratiquement avoir une
situation je dirais presque normal parce
que je dois naturellement encore séduire
un certain nombre de soi et puis des
examens dans les semaines qui viennent
et dans les mois qui viennent et bien je
peux dire effectivement que je me porte
le moins mal possible et je voudrais
avoir une pensée pour tous ceux qui sont
encore hospitalisés une pensée aussi
pour les familles des disparus est
souvent j'y pense parce que moi même mon
pronostic vital est engagé à deux
reprises ma famille a passé des moments
extrêmement difficiles et quand je pense
à toutes ces familles qui ont été
frappés et vous avez cité les chiffres à
l'instant un plus de 28000 dans notre
pays qui n'ont pas pu bénéficier non
plus 2 de ferrer monique soit religieuse
ou civile
entourés de leur famille entourés de
leurs amis eh bien on peut on nous hue
le drame parce que ces familles n'ont
pas pu effectuer leur devoir de mémoire
et leur travail de deuil
donc quand on est rescapé que moi j'ose
utiliser ce terme est bien on mesure la
chance que l'on a clairement jean luc
reitzer vous estimez que vous êtes un
miraculé côté le terme je sais pas
l'utiliser néanmoins c'est vrai comme je
vous le dis à deux reprises mon
pronostic vital a été engagé puisque
dans le cadre de cette mise dans le coma
s'était tout de suite au début comme
vous l'avez rappelé j'étais le premier
parlementaire à être infecté c'était
donc beau but mars
j'étais endormi au puis encore de coma
on a voulu commander mercy bay et ça
s'est très très mal passé il était
effectivement extrêmement agitées je ne
pouvais plus respirer tout ça sent les
médecins qui m'ont dit après bien sûr
moi je ne m'en souviens pas donc on a
été obligé de leurs études ou deuxième
fois ce qui en général à ce prix et donc
c'est à ces moments là que mon pronostic
vital a été engagé et que ma famille
surtout a beaucoup souffert parce que
d'heure en heure les informations
variées était souvent 13
amiens est très alarmante et donc voilà
c'est vrai que j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance terme miraculeux peut-être
peut-être exagéré mais c'est vrai que je
me suis super bien sorti comme le disait
les médecins me right there vous venez
de loin de très loin
y at il des moments vous avez perdu
espoir
oui il ya des moments où vraiment j'ai
perdu espoir lorsque j'avais pendant de
très nombreuses jours voire plusieurs
semaines
l'impossibilité de d'avaler de déglutir
je ne pouvais plus boire pas boire même
pas de look
je ne pouvais évidemment pas manger et
je ne vous cache pas qu'à ces moments là
effectivement le moral était au plus bas
et que la dépression n'était pas très
loin très loin donc à ce moment-là je
tiens à souligner le caractère humain du
personnel hospitalier
j'ai naturellement mesure de la
professionnalisme les médecins c'est eux
qui m'ont sauvé la vie les infirmières
les aides soignantes les personnes qui
sont venues dans la chambre tous les
jours pour la nettoyer pour désinfecter
ce qui devait l'être et bien d'autres
pas une de ces personnes qui passaient
dans ma chambre sans avoir un mot
d'encouragement et je me souviens
puisque vous parlions des moments
difficiles je me souviens effectivement
que lorsque moral était au plus bas bien
une ou deux affirmé venait de tenir la
même car elle ses deux bras en me disant
ben ça et dire ça reviendra mais comme
on ne savait pas comment cette maladie
évolue qu'est ce que touche le cerveau
elle peut toucher le coeur et peut
toucher des rares on ne savait pas
comment cette maladie pour le volume
donc moi j'avais effectivement le doute
et je me disais demain si tu peux plus
value si tu peux plus manger qu'elles
seront encore le plaisir de la vie et
donc ce moment là était particulièrement
difficile à vivre mais le côté humain du
personnel m'a énormément énormément aidé
je n'avais pas de visite pendant deux
mois j'ai vu ma maman nous pose la
première fois le 3 mai c'est-à-dire deux
mois après après mon hospitalisation et
encore de loin dans le couloir donc
quand on est seul comme ça c'est très
difficile à vivre nous avaient toujours
l'espoir parce que je suis je suis un
battant
et puis j'avais envie de vivre parce que
la vie se bourse avec ses difficultés
avec ses joies avec ses peines
mais la vie chez vous et donc ça valait
la peine de se battre j'ai fait de mon
mieux mais je répète je pense surtout à
ceux qui n'ont pas pu gagner cette
bataille et qu'ils sont plus là j'en ai
trahis their aujourd'hui le ségur de la
santé s'est ouvert justement pour voir
les hôpitaux les soignants aujourd'hui
vous voyez les choses différemment vous
soutenez plus que jamais ces soignants
dans leur lutte pour que leurs
conditions soient meilleurs salut c'est
heu l'air pendant 34 ans de ma ville la
ville d'altkirch dans le rhin
j'ai été président d'un conseil de
surveillance et d'administration de mon
hôpital josy mon hôpital tellement
j'étais attaché à celle du site et donc
je connais ce problème depuis de très
nombreuses années et je voulus au fil du
temps effectivement d'un sur les moyens
qu'ils soient humains qu'ils soient
financiers et de soi m'arrive est
maintenant un point de rupture et donc
il est impératif que et c'est la faute
de tout le gouvernement à moi je suis je
suis dit tu es là vous l'avez rappelé je
met tout le monde dans les facs dans ce
domaine là nous avons tous
collectivement commis de graves erreurs
nous pensions toujours que moi il y
avait de l'esa noir et puis moi ça
coûterait cher et bien c'est une grave
erreur on voit aujourd'hui que le
système implose et donc il faut
effectivement tirer les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé je bats bas de l'histoire
démarre il ya des commissions
parlementaires qui diront ce qui s'est
passé nous ferons valoriser revaloriser
vraiment vous avez vu nous sommes donc
dans le peloton de queue en matière de
niveau de vie de nos tests de nos
personnels hospitaliers
il faut réussir on arrive on investit
beaucoup dans les années 90 mais après
on a plus beaucoup investi on a vu le
nombre de respirateur qui manquait dans
notre pays par rapport à l'allemagne
et enfin ils font de nouveau rendre
attractives les professions de santé je
pense notamment à la présence de lucha
en milieu rural et semi rural le fameux
d'une russe clause est ce qu'il vous
plaît à poser pendant de très nombreuses
années
heureusement maintenant on l'a enlevé on
a supprimé le surnommeront cerise
et qu'à l'heure actuelle nous avons une
connerie de médecins nous avons une
démographie médicale qui est en pleine
crise et donc il faudra prendre là aussi
de mesures d'attractivité que des
collectivités aussi s'engage en mettant
à disposition des locaux gratuitement en
faisant souvent deux autres financières
pour permettre à tous les médecins de
s'installer pas simplement de les
grandes villes je le répète mais aussi
en milieu rural et semi rural ce sont
les leçon que je tire et je serai
naturellement à la pointe du combat dans
les années qui viennent pour faire
prendre conscience de la nécessité afin
de prendre des mesures concrètes et
directes
jean luc reitzer sur un plan plus global
cette fois ci la gestion de la crise par
le gouvernement vous avez évoqué les
masques on pourrait aussi parler des
tests pour vous clairement le
gouvernement at il commis des erreurs
comme l'affirment beaucoup je vous ai
dit je pense que le temps n'est pas à la
polémique cette crise n'est pas terminée
et je voudrais rendre attentif tout le
monde et notamment de l'eau chaude sur
le fait que la crise sanitaire que la
contagiosité de se livrer sur toujours
présent et donc il faut faire très
attention jeu pour le 17 un ennemi qui
est féroce
je vous écris beaucoup ont vécu le drame
de cette contagion et donc je rends tout
le monde attend ti sur la nécessité de
faire très attention et pour moi je vous
le répète ce pas le moment de la
polémique
par contre il y aura des commissions d
enquête parlementaire qui dans les
semaines dans l'émoi viendront elles
travailleront pour voir ce qui se
passait en tout cas il ya eu
manifestement en matière de masse et
aussi en matière de test il ya eu
maldonne
il ya eu des retards au démarrage il ya
eu peut-être aussi un certain nombre de
défaillances et on ce que moi surtout
j'ai constaté jeu les véhicules après
puisque toute cette période difficile
j'étais dans le coma je n'ai pas vécu
directement mais ce que j'ai surtout
constaté c'est que nous avons une sur
administration dans notre pays
vous savez qu'il ya combien de centaines
de millions de masques étaient tout
simplement bloqués à roissy charles de
gaulle passe
le ministère du budget nous les
appliquer des droits de douane pour
l'importation de ces masques alors qu'on
a manqué en france j'ai entendu pendant
mon hospitalisation à la télévision
comme ça allez un petit peu mieux j'ai
entendu un industriel français qui
disait qu'il avait atteinte à tout ce
qui est validé ah qu'est ce qu'ils
trouvaient vendons simply et ne pouvait
pas le vendre en france parce que
l'autorisation ne lui était pas accordé
par le ministère de la santé la haute
autorité de la santé
il a vraiment un problème de sueur et
administration de lourdeur et je pense
qu'il faudra là aussi en tirer les
leçons le plus rapidement possible car
ce plus pensable que nous puissions
prendre du retard par rapport à nos
voisins nous sommes quand même un pays
développé
nous avons des technologies
particulièrement en pointe et là
malheureusement dans la distribution des
masses dans la distribution des tests
nous étions là aussi dans la queue du
peloton et c'était triste à voir mais je
regrette amèrement
merci beaucoup jean luc addor de nous
avoir accordé ce temps députés l ère du
haut-rhin merci à vous la phase ii du
déconfinement une étape décisive pour la
reprise de l'économie de la vie sociale
des français preuve de la reprise
une grande partie des établissements
scolaires ouvriront leurs portes demain
un deuxième palier qui ne sera pas
uniforme sur tout le territoire mode
d'emploi avec thé au combat
c'était attendu par de nombreux français
les cafés bars et restaurants sont enfin
autorisés à rouvrir complètement en zone
verte dès demain et partiellement en
ile-de-france en guyane et à mayotte
dans ces trois territoires seuls les
terrasses pourront accueillir des
clients un dispositif qui satisfait ce
restaurateur parisien
je pense que oui ça va un peu nous aider
justement avec la vente à emporter si on
arrive à gérer les deux avant la
terrasse que sa vente à emporter ça nous
aide parce que dresser une visibilité de
fait d'être couverts ça permet de
montrer qu'on existe encore dans
beaucoup de bars et de restaurants à
paris il ya des habitués et les habitués
là on a vu depuis un mois et ça va
continuer vraiment nous soutenir donc
ils seront d'un donc je pense qu'en fait
vu le peu de tables qu'on aura en
terrasse on sera toujours plein une
disparité qui s'appliquera aussi aux
hébergements touristiques qui rouvriront
dès le 2 juin en zone verte mais pas
avant le 22 du mois en zone orange même
différence pour les piscines salles de
sport parc de loisirs salle de spectacle
et pour les théâtres
autre bonne nouvelle pour le tourisme
plages lacs et musées seront dans leur
ensemble accessible au public dès demain
pour les professionnels du secteur
l'heure est au soulagement même si cette
réouverture dans des conditions
sanitaires strictes chamboule de
nombreux établissements donc de ce côté
là c'est la partie sommes donc les
jeunes prendront part cette porte et
sortiront par celle ci n'y aura pas de
croisement de personnes et en plus on
valeur ajoutée des distributeurs de
savon à chaque que le ch a créé à faro
est également à l'intérieur des douches
par ailleurs les déplacements des
français ne seront plus limités
la barrière des 100 km et enlever les
déplacements entre métropole et outre
mer reste toutefois conditionnée à des
motifs impérieux
enfin les déplacements hors de france
sont pour l'instant impossible
prochain étape du déconfinement le 22
juin le premier ministre l'avait annoncé
le 28 mai les restaurants cafés et bars
vont pouvoir à nouveau accueillir les
clients b
demain l'étape devant être séparés d'un
mètre minimum les groupes de plus de 10
personnes sont interdits tout comme la
consommation debout dans les bars nous
avons recueilli les réactions de ces
restaurateurs à paris et à
levallois-perret dans les hauts-de-seine
on s'organise par rapport aux
contraintes sont en train de faire les
plans de table avec les séparations d'un
mètre entre les clients on met tous les
protocoles en place pour éviter tout
contact avec la clientèle
les gels hydro alcooliques les masques
on met en place un système de cartes à
et des qr codes plus qui te contacte
papier donc le client il arrive qu'il
prend son téléphone il scanne le qr code
il a tout le menu du restaurant il peut
commander après que serveur on a déjà
simulé la terrasse puisqu'on peut ouvrir
que la terrasse on a cette chance
d'avoir une terrasse donc on a stimulé
les l'espacement des tables pour la
terrasse avec un mètre de distance entre
chaque table on a évidemment tour
nettoyer tour désinfecter on a mis en
place les postes pour le gel
hydro alcoolique et on s'est équipée en
masques et en visière pour le bas on ne
prépare le gel les masques les gains on
désinfecte on essaie de faire la
traçabilité tout le monde ne soit assuré
que peuvent être relax et mangé un très
bon coup on était plus qu'un patient
parce que ça commençait à faire un petit
peu long même très long et encore nous
on fait partie des d'aider des gens
qu'avant une terrasse pour pouvoir
commencer à travailler donc on a de la
chance il ya des gens qui n'auront pas
de terrasse qui pourront pas travailler
comme nous maintenant on va essayer de
faire un petit peu travaillé notre
établissement pour pouvoir payer le
personnel et puis surtout payer les
loyers aussi parce que les loyers ils
ont été arrêtés et repoussé mais bon ça
ne change pas le problème il va falloir
quand même qu'on les paye vous qu'on
s'arrange avec nos propriétaires quoi
bon pour en parler nous sommes avec des
vis ni qui possède deux établissements
paris avec une terrasse et l'autre sens
bonsoir david ni merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on vous
imagine on en pleins préparatifs c'est
le grand jour celui que vous attendiez
tant de demain où il ya un petit peu de
stress parce que eh bien ma foi c'est
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre tout ça
c'est une situation assez inédite et
pour être hyper honnête
moi j'ai deux tables en terrasse dans un
de mes restaurants et dans l'autre j'ai
pas vraiment de terrasses donc je vais
je vais pas foncer la tête baissée je
vais y aller avec prudence dans le sens
où il ya quand même une crise sanitaire
qui est toujours en cours et j'ai pas
envie de risquer la santé de les
habituer juste pour récupérer quelques
tables en terrasse
donc là on est en train de regarder la
mairie a mis en place un dispositif la
mairie de paris je précise ami andy en
place un dispositif qui permet aux
restaurateurs aux commerçants de
récupérer un petit peu des bouts de
trottoirs ou de places de stationnement
et là on est en train de voir et je suis
plutôt précautionneux donc je vais y
aller assez doucement dans la semaine je
vais regarder tirer une table d'une
deuxième mais toujours en gardant à
l'esprit la sécurité de mes habitués
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut préciser
pour nos téléspectateurs que la maire de
paris
a donné son accord pour une extension
gratuite des terrasses notamment sur des
places de livraison 3 place apparemment
de stationnement pour augmenter votre
terrasse comment vous sentez les choses
où on a compris vous étiez prudent mais
c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à s'imaginer
notamment pour le voisinage
voilà ça risque peut-être de créer un
joyeux désordre on va dire dans la
capitale moi je pense que ça va être un
petit gars le risque que ça soit un peu
la fête de la musique pendant deux
semaines où je pense que tout le monde
est un peu traiter le problème à sa
sauce je pense à des collègues qui ont
déjà commencé à mettre des tables
partout et et je pense que il faut
repenser on réinvente un petit peu la
façon de vivre ensemble et il ya des
nouvelles règles il ya des règles
sanitaires et puis est aussi plein de
gens comme vous l'avez eue du lot dans
le documentaire qui s'inquiète aussi de
la santé financière de leur
établissement j'en fais partie et donc
il faut réussir à concilier tout ça je
pense être prudent mais c'est vrai je
pense que dans deux semaines ça va être
un petit peu c'est trash arrive arrive
justement parlons-en de la rentabilité
parce que c'est pas facile d'être
rentable quand on doit mettre un mètre
entre les tables quand on vous demande
parce que s'il faut le rappeler de
fermer à 22 heures à paris
est ce que on imagine qu'il ya plusieurs
restaurants bas qui vont préférer rester
fermés on part faute de rentabilité ou
vous espérez quand même rentrer dans vos
frais avec ces restrictions très
importantes
je pense que c'est vraiment au cas par
cas moi personnellement c'est pour ça
que je préfère pas foncer la rentabilité
pas vraiment au rendez vous en ce moment
je crois que tous les parisiens qui sont
des consignes et ont envie de grand air
ont passé des moments ensemble ont pas
envie de se limiter à avoir un mètre de
distance donc on voit beaucoup de gens
sur le canal sur l'île saint louis dans
et en plus ça clair la réouverture des
parcs je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de
pique nique et c'est compréhensible et
je pense que suivant les cas ceux qui
ont des grosses terrasse et qui ont une
grande une grande clientèle d'habitués
ils vont réussir à
trouver cette clientèle petit à petit
maintenant faut voir comment ça va se
mettre en place
est ce que tout le monde a joué le jeu
est ce que au début ils vont jouer le
jeu puis après non je pense qu'il faut
il faut garder à l'esprit qu'il ya quand
même une épidémie à combattre avant tout
et il ya lit avec précaution alors la
maire du 9e delphine bürkli estime que
les choses se sont fait un petit peu
dans la précipitation quelle est votre
opinion sur ce point j'ai pas si on peut
dire précipitations dans le sens où si
on m'avait dit 2020 on va voir on va
finir sur des gains on va commencer sur
des grèves et ensuite on a enchaîné avec
eux une épidémie une épidémie mondiale
je pense que je veux je j'aurais reekoye
c'est c'est un peu un scénario
hollywoodien
je crois qu'il ya pas c'est difficile
aujourd'hui d'avoir un manuel de bonne
conduite serre que tout le monde à un
milliard de deux scénarios à équilibrer
on voit aux états unis ils ont choisi de
favoriser l'économie sur la santé des
gens et on voit le résultat est ici on a
de la chance parce que ne rien on a
quand même un gouvernement qui a mis en
place le chômage partiel on a pas d un
peu de solidarité qui se crée en tout
cas dans les corps de métier on essaie
de faire entendre nos droits les
bailleurs sont assez flexibles même si
effectivement un jour faudra les payer
y'a pas un guide je pense que c'est dur
aujourd'hui de de dire s'est précipitée
ou ses possibilités celle ci assure
inédite et après ça chacun d'eux
d'essayer de faire au mieux je pense
clairement est ce que vous espérez le 22
juin que ces restrictions se lève qu'est
ce qu'on vit dans votre métier quels
sont vos attentes vos espoirs
je pense que là ce qui est le ressenti
dans les métiers c'est effectivement
tous ceux qui ont des restaurants sans
terrasse comme moi on attend le 22 juin
on attend de pouvoir refaire notre
métier de pouvoir ré accueillir des gens
de pouvoir leur présenter une expérience
l'impression que j'ai en baladant à
paris en allant en allant travailler
c'est que la plupart des gens négligent
un petit peu le l'épidémie j'apprends
qu'ils m'ont fait plus trop trop
attention donc encore une fois prendre
avec des pincettes et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'attentes
on est tous très très impatient de
revenir au travail surtout passé de 60
70 heures par semaine
rien c'est pas négligeable quoi ça ne
vous fait pas peur de faire un petit peu
le gendarme parce qu'on rappelle qu'il
faudra un masque quand quelqu'un se lève
pour aller aux toilettes par exemple de
satam il faudrait qu'il porte un masque
de vous mettre dans la position du
gendarme c'est difficile engager votre
responsabilité
je pense ça dans le sens où à la fin
c'est la santé de mes clients qui me qui
m'importe est ce un peu le papa est le
papa et les enfants kouassi s'il faut
rappeler liés aux enfants de ce mode ne
pas mettre les mains dans la flamme je
le ferai parce que j'ai une
responsabilité envers mon staff envers
les clients qui viennent manger de la
même façon que respecte toutes les
consignes sanitaires pour leur servir
les meilleurs plats les mercredis sion
possible j'ai aussi envie que les gens
qui viennent au restaurant se sentent à
l'aise et qu'on ne puisse revoir des
nouvelles saisons de normalité on va
dire qu'on puisse voir un retour à la
normale ensemble et si pour ça faut que
pendant deux semaines on leur demande de
mettre un masque pendant deux semaines
on leur demande de patienter un peu plus
loin de prendre des distances
on le fera en tout cas on vous souhaite
le meilleur ainsi qu'aux autres
restaurateurs bon courage pour
l'ouverture demain des vies ni d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt franz
tost est avec nous dans quelques
instants direction les états unis est en
proie à des violences depuis la mort
lundi dernier 2
floyd dans une interpellation des
violences qui ont touché également des
journalistes agressés arrêtés ou ciblés
par des tirs lors de ces manifestations
puis nous parlerons du dossier du break
6 qui resurgit un la semaine est
décisive reprise des négociations entre
l'union européenne et londres afin de
tenter de trouver un accord commercial
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande île interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la fontaine de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar c'est trop fine
il ya un tournant et on se remet à vivre
mais dans une autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait simple jamais plaint
d'une décision à vraisemblable pour vous
ça dépend quelle valeur on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat moral
débats éthiques
[Musique]
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur leurs épaules
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire non plus
on pouvait être extrêmement efficients
sur le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes l'art du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il ya un état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière exponentielle ça
veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon intervention
dans la crise du coc vite 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
et responsables du fisc alors que l' oms
recommandait le port du masque par les
populations la parole publique a
longtemps menti sur sa nécessité pour ne
pas avoir la triste absence du stop
requis la décision de confinement
s'imposait compte-tenu du manque de
matériel permettant d'autres solutions
mais en freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise les connaissent l'état ne
pourra plus est l'état providence que
nous avons que tour à doha était
cimetière de certaines espérances en
pensant que le progrès faisait de nous
des hommes dieu et que les technocrates
avec les du monde de demain les
conséquences de la crise oblige à
repenser nos modèles la découverte du
télétravail l'intérêt de consommer des
produits locaux le besoin de solidarité
vont faire évoluer une population qui a
découvert qu'elle était mortel
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait pas égaux devant le projet
politique
la recherche la place qu'elles devraient
avoir parce que la recherche est un
élément central dans la prise en compte
des très très grand défi auquel nous
sommes aimés en particulier le défi
qu'il s'est conséquences et notamment
les problèmes ni là c'est la première
mêlée qui va y en avoir d'autres
il faut qu'ils aient une prise de
conscience collective vraiment
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vos jouets
à lévis mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on paie pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas pas seulement d'elle
même elle parle aussi de comment créer
cette cercle vertueux avec les villes
des alentours
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash vous parlerons de tout
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission il est 21h heure de paris
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité
l'amérique qui s'embrassent pillage leur
ouvre feu dans plusieurs dizaines de
villes la nuit dernière et garde
nationale déployé une semaine d'heure à
la suite de la mort de l'afro-américain
georgia floyd lors d'une interpellation
et des journalistes agressés et ciblés
par des tirs lors de ces rassemblements
certains dénoncent une atteinte grave à
la liberté de la presse le secrétaire
général de l'onu appelle lui à enquêter
sur les violences policières le break si
c'était nouveau leur des pourparlers
entre l'union européenne et londres une
semaine décisive pour tenter de trouver
un accord commercial
le premier ministre boris johnson
participera personnellement à ces
accusations le négociateur européen
michel barnier a lui souligné hier dans
une interview au journal britannique the
times que le temps pressait
le temps des alliances à l'aune des
municipales et surtout à 24 heures de la
date limite pour le dépôt des listes au
second tour des élections elle est en
sont revers et socialiste reste au coeur
des débats comme c'est le cas à paris la
maire sortante anne hidalgo poursuit ses
négociations avec davy belliard qui a
posé ses conditions
[Musique]
l'état n'assure plus la prise en charge
complète du chômage partiel à compter
d'aujourd'hui les entreprises vont
contribuer à la dépense mais rien ne
change pour les indemnités du salarié un
premier pas vers la levée du dispositif
qui inquiète beaucoup alors que se
profile la crise économique après la
crise sanitaire
[Musique]
va-t-il y avoir une septième nuit
consécutive deux aux états unis et ce
une semaine après la mort de djordje
floyd un afro américain décédé au cours
d'une interpellation policière
les protestataires dénoncent les
violences policières nouvelles scènes de
pillage et d'affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre la
nuit dernière dans plusieurs dizaines de
villes notamment autour de la maison
blanche
les policiers ont tiré des gaz lacrymo
pour disperser la foule réunie malgré un
couvre feu décrété et un dispositif
similaire dans une quarantaine de villes
avec des milliers de soldats de la garde
nationale déployés dans 15 états au
centre jeunesse chicago seattle houston
et bien sûr minneapolis d'où est partie
la contestation
la ville du minnesota - camion-citerne a
forcé le passage
on sent sur les manifestants
heureusement pas de blessé et derek
chauvin le policier blanc mis en cause
inculpé d'homicide involontaire devait
comparaître aujourd'hui devant un
tribunal
comparution reportée au 8 juin réaction
du procureur de minnesota au sujet de
l'enquète des youyous jour bikrat cette
affaire est inhabituel en raison de la
façon dont monsieur floyd a été tué et
qui est imputable à l'accusé qui est qui
était un officier de police de
minneapolis et cela n'est pas inhabituel
dans le sens où le cabinet du procureur
général s'occupe des affaires pénales et
travaille tout le temps avec les comptes
et ce n'est pas quelque chose auquel
nous ne sommes pas habitués
et donc je veux juste faire savoir au
public que nous souhaitons que justice
soit rendue
nous recherchons la vérité nous le
faisons vigoureusement et nous
poursuivrons les individus responsables
et je vais vous demander votre confiance
car certaines personnes veulent
certainement savoir chaque détail sur
lequel nous travaillons nous ne pourrons
pas partager cela avec vous et lors des
manifestations anti police des dizaines
de journalistes ont été ciblés par les
forces de l'ordre du quasi jamais vu
dans un pays où la presse bénéficie de
garanties constitutionnelles
généralement respecté l'adage abderrazak
pardon
ok vous pouvez me dire pourquoi je suis
arrêté monsieur pourquoi je suis arrêté
monsieur la vidéo a fait le tour du
monde
oscar jimenez envoyé spécial de la
chaîne cnn est arrêtée menottée en plein
direct alors qu'ils couvrent les émeutes
à minneapolis
la chaîne américaine dénonce rapidement
une atteinte grave à la liberté de la
presse un journaliste de cnn est son
équipe de production ont été arrêtés ce
matin à minneapolis en faisant leur
travail malgré s'être identifié une
violation manifeste du premier
amendement
si le premier amendement de la
constitution américaine garantit en
effet la liberté de la presse
sur le terrain c'est autre chose
quarante trois reporters ont été arrêtés
dans des manifestations aux états unis
depuis 2017 et l'investiture de donald
trump
depuis le début des manifestations anti
police des dizaines de reporters ont été
prises à partie par les forces de
l'ordre certains directement visés par
des tirs de balles en caoutchouc ou de
gaz lacrymogène
c'est le cas par exemple de molly et
n'essaie fisc journaliste au los angeles
times elle a couvert les conflits en
irak en afghanistan les émeutes raciales
de 2014 à ferguson ait jamais dit elle
la police ne lui a jusqu'ici tiré dessus
oui a été identifié comme journaliste et
ils ont tiré sur nous des cartouches de
gaz lacrymogène
j'ai été touché à la jambe nous avons
demandé où allons nous allons nous ils
n'ont pas répondu
ils ne nous ont pas diriger
ils ont juste tiré sur nous un
témoignage loin d'être isolé un
correspondant de cbs michael jones a
pour sa part rapporté que son équipe
avait été visée par des balles en
caoutchouc alors qu'elle se trouvait
loin du front regardez cela fait 15 ans
que je couvre des manifestations à
travers les états unis
c'est la première fois que je vois la
police est ciblé la presse activement et
intentionnellement avec des balles en
caoutchouc des lacrymogènes et des
arrestations
ce sont des scènes qui rappellent la
chine ou l'iran nous restons déterminés
à montrer au pays ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
à louiseville dans le kentucky c'est une
jeune journaliste de la chaîne locale
wave fraigneau ce qui à son tour a été
ciblé quatre lignes à rust intervenait
elle aussi en direct ça va tu m'as fait
tirer dessus
qu'at il dit ça va balles de caoutchouc
ce sont des balles de poivre qui sont
ils tirent sur notre équipe directement
sur nous
pourquoi font-ils ça me tire sur le
caméraman je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
ils ne savent pas qu'ils sont en face de
la caméra à liverchies journaliste
vedette de la chaîne msnbc ci a été
touché par une balle en caoutchouc en
plein direct lui aussi est alors qu'il
se trouvait à une bonne distance d'un
rassemblement à minneapolis est là
d'abord cru à un tir involontaire avant
de se raviser
quand après avoir levé les mains en
l'air et crier médias les policiers lui
ont répondu on s'en fiche
avant de tirer une seconde fois les gars
je me suis fait tirer dessus attendez
mais le cas le plus grave c'est
certainement celui de linda tirado à
minneapolis
cette photographe indépendante du
tennessee a laissé tomber ses lunettes
de protection un court instant
avant d'être atteinte par une balle de
caoutchouc au visage à l'hôpital elle a
appris qu'elle ne recouvre aurait
probablement pas la vue de la gauche
l institut fried a mauvaise presse et le
site bell incat indiquent avoir recensé
une cinquantaine d' exemples de
journalistes américains je cite agressés
par les forces de l'ordre et des
violences sans précédent contre les
journalistes que reporters sans
frontières attribue à donald trump la
diabolisation des médias car entretenu
donald trump pendant des années porte
aujourd'hui ses fruits
rsf avait alerté sur les conséquences de
cette flagrante hostilité envers les
médias et nous assistons aujourd'hui à
un déchaînement de violence sans
précédent contre les journalistes aux
états unis depuis son élection donald
trump sts attaque régulièrement aux
médias le président américain les accuse
de déformer la vérité voire de fabriquer
de fausses informations dans le but de
lui nuire
le locataire de la maison blanche
qualifie même la presse d' ennemis du
peuple et pour en parler nous sommes
avec yannick mireur politologue
spécialiste des états unis bonsoir
yannick mireur merci d'être avec nous on
vient de voir un tout c'est à tintin
manifestement contre les journalistes
américains en ce moment que kate il en
train de se passer
aux etats unis selon vous écouter dans
une certaine mesure on peut dire que ce
qu'anthony que face à lui-même
particulier les emballements historiques
comme les années 70 aux etats unis
donc ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui est
assez rare sur la question de la presse
que vous évoquez cela nous confirme
simplement se préserve quand même des
commentaires que l'on pourrait faire que
il y à une exercice du pouvoir américain
assez loin des pratiques délictuelles
qui tendrait plutôt à privilégier un
discours d'unité nationale d'après ce
que des procédures
politique des protocoles politique et de
soutenir aussi la constitution des états
unis
on voit bien qu'il ya des positions si
vous voyez la dérive du département la
justice en particulier qui nous place
dans une situation assez particulière
qui éclaire évidemment l'élection
présidentielle à venir sur les questions
des émeutes elle-même moi je pense
élargir la chose parce que la dimension
purement raciale malheureusement passe à
côté d'un certain nombre de choses aussi
révoltante qu'elle puisse être elle
s'inscrit dans une histoire et une
culture de dénis plus large je vous dis
à trois points clés le premier est celui
de la condition de la communauté noire
aux etats unis plus marginalisées
généralement plus représenter la
population carcérale pu représenter
aussi en dessous du seuil de pauvreté y
est situation sociale pacifique la
population américaine est un autre sujet
que suit la police et des règles
d'engagement d'appréhension ou
d'arrestations des forces de police
étaient line est une littérature et la
presse abonde ans qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude dans d'autres pays sur ces
sujets une structure institutions
policières aussi que les râles d'un côté
et pui basée sur les états de l'eau sur
vous le rappelle 18 min département de
police à travers le territoire américain
tous indépendants avec nos frères plein
il ya aussi l'amendement numéro 2 c'est
à dire la liberté du port d'armes créé
une situation quand une particulière à
la fois pour l'exercice du métier de la
police et 8 pour les manifestants
dansent qui se comptent s'y confrontent
violemment comme c'est le cas maintenant
aux forces de l'ordre on a parlé des
tensions des violences contre les
journalistes on parle de ces émeutes
comment on explique cela aujourd'hui
évidemment la crise sanitaire beaucoup
pointent du doigt également donald trump
qui est accusé pour beaucoup d' attiser
justement ces violences et ces tensions
dans le pays pour évidemment regretter
certaines maladresses et
pour savoir qu'on perspective de tout
cela le vote noir ne se portent pas
naturellement sur monsieur traduit
habituellement comme le boss il faut
aussi aux états unis il très
majoritairement 87% tuant le parti
démocrate et ce sera probablement le cas
de joe by day continue de sa
personnalité sur pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle
en revanche bon l'intensité de ce que
l'on voit est particulière gelé bien
devenir tout à l'heure je prend
cependant que la bavure policière
qualifiant la bavure à ce stade se
répétera et qu' il n'y a ici une
inflammation voilà de la population
blanche et noire d'ailleurs devant de
tels actes de tels écarts policiers je
vous rappelle quand même que le biais de
police en question a déjà été réprimandé
fait l'objet déjà de deux remarques à
plusieurs reprises dans sa carrière donc
c'est un sujet très particulier mais qui
si je puis dire imprime une réalité
sociale beaucoup plus large
les 80 barack obama l'ont pas permis
cela ne suffirait pas évidemment de
rétablir de donner une réponse sociale
et économique à la communauté noire aux
etats-unis je pense que c'est ça le
premier sujet a évoqué et les
manifestations
leur violence servat s'est mal au fond
cette cause elles ont plutôt tendance à
effaré et a joué le jeu en quelques
sortes faire le genou l'électoral de
duperie nantes rennes par exemple quand
il tape consolider sa base électorale
majoritairement blanche est
majoritairement aussi de classes
populaires aujourd'hui clairement
yannick mireur ce sera ma dernière
question comment on s'en sort parce que
dans les années 60 il y avait de vrais
leaders qui était prêt à se mettre
autour d'une table martin luther king
avait johnson y avait les kennedy
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu' on n'est pas
dans ce schéma là comment se sortir de
cette crise qui peut aller en de mal en
pis oui elle c'est assez difficile de
prévoir une crise comme la crise
sanitaire dans une certaine mesure c'est
à dire qui était très affable foire
comme comme très incendiaires aussi
relire les propos qui sont parfois tenus
d'un côté comme de l'autre
exit la polarisation et une
confrontation difficile de prévoir ce
qui peut se passer
sinon appel à l'ordre et à omni veste en
a qui ont je veux dire est établi leur
leurs arguments si on peut dire à
revenir à une position plus simple les
origines les élections présidentielles
ont lieu dans quelques mois les
conventions les investitures et
candidats démocrates d'un côté
républicain d'autres peut-il se passer
aussi au sein du parti républicain en
quarts nature présidentielle ce serait
un cas unique mais ce serait avoir je
pense ce sera cela il va définir les
thématiques de la campagne chine d'un
côté et de pousser le gouvernement
américain de monsieur trinquent
de l'autre des questions sociales et la
crise économique ont coûté hier
l'ensemble de ces mecs là à l'intérieur
de ça la question
une fois de plus du port d'armes
surtout de règles d'engagement de la
police de la frugalité policière plus
accessible aux etats-unis peut-être
cahier à manquera pas non plus de
masquer les attaques des forces de
l'ordre par des délinquants ça existe
aussi quand même aux états unis
je pense que c'est le débat public on
peut guère espérer mieux
à ce stade qui permettra de le traiter
le sujet je ne dis pas nécessairement de
l'améliorer mais ce sera la reine
démocratique avec une situation assez
nette entre probablement dossier tram
est certainement monsieur barry dette de
l'autre côté qui sera la reine de deux
débats de confrontation pour le peuple
américain
merci anika miller d'avoir été avec mon
direct sur arte france pour nous
apporter votre analyse
semaine cruciale pour le royaume uni les
négociations sur le break sites ont
repris aujourd'hui avec un seul objectif
trouver un accord commercial avec
l'union européenne
les détails avec valentin car proscrit
si tout tourne autour de la crise
sanitaire du coc vie de 19 depuis
maintenant quatre mois
michel barnier lui n'a pas cessé de
chercher des solutions aux désaccords
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne sur le break site le divorce
acté depuis le 31 janvier dernier
les deux parties doivent désormais se
mettre d'accord sur les nouvelles
relations surtout commerciale
et le chef des négociations sur le bric
site pour l'union européenne n'est pas
très optimiste le royaume uni a fait
trois pas en arrière par rapport aux
engagements pris à l'origine nous nous
souvenons très bien du texte que nous
avons négocié avec boris johnson et nous
voulons simplement qu'ils soient
respectées à la lettre
sinon il n'y aura pas d'accord des mots
durs quelques semaines après une période
de négociation à la mi mai marquée par
l'absence totale d'avancé si le temps
presse
une prolongation de la période de
transition qui doit s'achever à la fin
de l'année peut tout de même être
demandée avant le 1er juillet prochain
problème les deux parties campent sur
leurs positions
bruxelles souhaite un level playing
field soit un accord large avec des
garanties afin d'éviter une dérégulation
de l'économie britannique à son
détriment
de son côté londres demandent un accord
de libre-échange classique pour pouvoir
préserver son autonomie
une véritable impasse qui commence à
agacer les deux camps l'union européenne
veut essentiellement que nous obéissons
aux règles de son club même si nous n'en
sommes plus membres et elle veut le même
accès à nos zones de pêche que celui
dont elle bénéficie actuellement tout en
limitant notre accès à ces marchés il
reste difficile de parvenir à un accord
mutuellement bénéfique tant que l'union
européenne maintient une telle approche
idéologique
à l'exception de ces quelques ouvertures
modeste aucun progrès n'a été possible
sur les autres sujets les plus
difficiles
le royaume uni n'a pas engagé de vraies
discussions sur la question du level
playing field quoi qu'il en dise sans un
cadre clair et efficace de level paine
field sans un accord équilibré sur la
pêche
il n'y aura pas qu'il ne pourra pas y
avoir d'accord sur notre partenariat
économique et commercial
l'espoir subsiste quand même londres et
bruxelles ont au moins une envie commune
éviter à tout prix le no deal qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'année si aucun accord
n'est trouvé
dans ce cas là ce sera à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce de fixer les règles
reste à voir lequel des deux camps sera
prêt à faire des concessions pour éviter
un désastre économique et pour en parler
nous sommes avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous dans quel contexte
s'ouvre ces nouvelles négociations
mais le le royaume uni grand bretagne a
quitté l'union européenne
le 31 janvier dernier après 1 47 ans de
vie commune
depuis cette date il n'y a plus un seul
britannique à l'intérieur des
institutions européennes ni au parlement
ni à la commission ni au secrétariat du
conseil et l'accord de divorce prévoit
en effet hubert de 11 mois donc jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2020 pour négocier le
régime futur des relations entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne
et c'est là dessus que en effet
peut-être corps d'un virus et dans et
bien les négociations n'ont fait aucun
progrès effectivement cela commence à
devenir relativement turgeon alors quels
sont les objectifs de l'union européenne
l'union européenne souhaite avoir un
accord de partenariat substantielle avec
le royaume uni et l à d'autres ça dans
sa position
trois points très importants qui sont
premièrement bien sûr de d'accepter que
le royaume uni est un accès au marché
unique quitte à marcher un avantage
considérable pour le royaume-uni 450
millions de consommateurs et un marché
très riche mais à condition de respecter
les conditions de concurrence notamment
les règles sociales et les règnes de
l'environnement en deuxième lieu
l'union européenne demande à ce que ces
pêcheurs et concerne surtout les
pêcheurs français et belges puissent
continuer à avoir accès aux zones de
pêche traditionnelle qui se trouve en
effet dans le dans les eaux britanniques
et puis en troisième lieu le en
troisième lieu les compétences de la
cour de justice européenne de l'union
européenne qui pourrait être amené à
trancher les litiges
lorsque le droit européen est en cause
alors ceci est la position de l'union
européenne est dans le fond depuis le
début de l'année l'union européenne
considère que cet accord sera difficile
à négocier et la tradition de l'union
européenne c'est des dossiers dans les
détails ces négociations qui durent
longtemps et l'opinion de l'union
européenne c'est qu' il serait
préférable que le royaume uni
grande-bretagne demande avant le 30 juin
date qui est inscrite dans dans la corde
de 2,2 de départ
et bien qu avant le 30 juin les
britanniques demandent une deuxième
année de transition c'est prévu dans
l'accord qui serait l'année de lui je
veux dire à ceux qui donneraient tout le
temps de négocier tranquillement à
l'accord équilibré donc ça se comprend
les objectifs de l'union européenne
quatre sont maintenant les objectifs de
boris johnson alors doris hudson nuit à
l inverse il est pressé il est pressé il
vit depuis le début me dis pourquoi
faire des négociations aussi long
pourtant il que l'émir bruxelles parce
que dans sa jeunesse il a été
correspondant de presse russell et
connaît bien la mégane écossais loire
donc il sait que ça va prendre du temps
mais précisément il dit faisons une
négociation politique après tout ce que
nous demandons c'est assez simple c'est
le libre échange
vous l'avez fait avec le canada faites
le avec nous et on peut faire ça en très
peu de temps
en tout état de cause je ne
rendrait pas de prolongation d'ici le 30
juin pour obtenir une année
supplémentaire l'année 2021 c'est donc
une position tactique une sorte de bras
de fer de façon à essayer de bousculer
l'union européenne
sinon les cils 30 juin du moins d'ici le
mois de décembre et il espère l'emporter
il espère l'emporter dans ces conditions
là je pense que c'est ce que son
électorat lui demande d'ailleurs puisque
son électorat ne veut plus être soumis à
des règles européennes ne veut plus être
soumis à des juridictions européennes et
veut recouvrer son indépendance sa
souveraineté nationale intégral alors le
dossier claude on le sert de bréxent ita
sonnant révélé de sérieux des surprises
à quoi doit-on et peut-on surtout
s'attendre logiquement il est tout à
fait probable que l'on arrive à un new
deal
le 31 décembre prochain et par
conséquent il faut en tout état de cause
si préparer parce que cette situation
sera dommageable pour toutes les
économies
celle de l'union européenne comme
l'économie britannique
mais avec boris johnson il faut
s'attendre à tout et il n'est pas du
tout impossible que boris johnson à un
moment quelconque d'ici la fin de
l'année sorte une proposition de
compromis qui permettrait à des jeunes
de la négociation et que l'on arrive à
négocier quelque chose qui permette
d'aboutir
alors évidemment cela fera aussi appel
aux avocats la capacité d'imagination
des diplomates de l'union européenne et
des piles diplomates britanniques qui
probablement feront aussi des
suggestions
donc comme vous le savez je suis
optimiste donc tout n'est pas encore
perdu et on verra à merci claude à
blanche réseau expert en relations
internationales d'avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre analyse dans le rêve
dans le reste de l'actualité est leur dû
des confinement les mesures sanitaires
s'assouplissent dans plusieurs pays
résultat de nombreux lieux rouvrent
leurs portes le grand bazar à istanbul
le colisée à rome les centres
commerciaux à tokyo tour d'horizon en
images
où
demande le monde sur le tas c'est un
sentiment d'excitation un sentiment de
grande excitation
nous avons l'impression que ce monument
historique nous appartient mais les
touristes manque
[Musique]
tous
nous avons dû procéder à des changements
on a déplacé les bureaux pour qu'ils
soient dans une configuration différente
de celle à laquelle les enfants étaient
habitués avant de revenir aujourd'hui
nous avons également été très conscients
de la nécessité de garder les choses
aussi normal et cohérente que possible
le retour à l'école devrait être une
expérience vraiment positif pour eux
[Musique]
west avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du second tour des
municipales prévues les 28 juin les
tractations entre les candidats pour de
possibles alliances battent leur plein
alors que la date limite des dépôts des
listes approche puis nous parlerons du
chômage partiel à compter d'aujourd'hui
l'état n'assure plus la prise en charge
complète du dispositif
[Musique]
lorsque c'est la question du jour
dans quel monde on a envie de vivre
il faut qu'on chante le terrain que
c'est la seule façon de proposer une
alternative
je pense en réalité qu' on va de plus en
plus à l'est vers le télétravail selon
oddo que ça du 1er au 13 avril à 2020
83% des entreprises avaient entre 10 %
et plus de 80% de leurs collaborateurs
en télétravail d'une fantastique
opportunité et on a utilisé pour sa
insolites etc et la visioconférence
il ya infiniment plus efficace le
numérique est il le grand gagnant de la
crise du convient de 19 c sur que
facebook et google ainsi qu amazon qui
n'a d'après logistique a tout
révolutionné sont pour l'instant les
grands gagnants de cette fuite
en revanche nos libertés sont les
grandes perdantes c'est l'application
d'un modèle mais c'est l'application
d'un modèle qui n'est pas le nôtre est
le problème il vient de là
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un frontale de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refera met à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines la moitié de
la planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais plaint d'une
décision à vraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend telles valeurs on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral débats éthiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct du
rt france merci de nous rejoindre j
moins un avant le dépôt des listes pour
le second tour des municipales prévues
le 28 juin le temps des alliances et des
négociations s'achèvent entre les partis
politiques
les enjeux de ce scrutin très
particuliers commencent à se dessiner
dans les grandes villes françaises tour
d'horizon avec des villes khalifa
s'allier pour mieux régner voilà la
ligne de conduite de ce second tour des
élections municipales et tous les coups
sont permis pour pouvoir accéder au
trône mais dans les 34 1968 communes
françaises le son de cloche n'est pas le
même partout
un marcheur peut s'allier avec un
républicain dans une ville tandis que
dans l'autre on préféra discuter avec
les verts autour d'une table et bannir
les républicains une configuration qui
crève les yeux a lille par exemple
socialistes et écologistes lillois vont
s'affronter dans une triangulaire avec
la république en marche dans une
configuration assez inédite
les résultats du premier tour ordonne
29,8 % pour madame aubry et 24 53 % pour
monsieur ben ali arrivé deuxième devant
la candidate la république en marche
violette est ce qu'il vous tu essaies et
17,50 3% si la gauche avait cumulé ces
scores la victoire était acquise et
depuis 1977 écologistes et socialistes
dirigent ensemble
la ville de lille mais les tensions dans
la majorité n'ont jamais cessé durant le
troisième mandat est de mère de madame
aubry et le divorce était inévitable
on a constaté à regret qu'il n'y avait
pas d' envie de communiquer avec nous
ils n'ont pas montré dans vie de faire
un accord dès le premier soir du premier
tour martine aubry n'est pas en colère
mais elle regrette et elle prend acte
pour les verts la seule responsable de
cette rupture et la maire ps
il y dénonce une campagne électorale
abrupt de la part de martine aubry
elle qui voulait garder le contrôle
absolu et sans partage il déplore
également un manque d'intérêt pour leurs
propositions à des tensions qui pourront
bien faire le jeu des marcheurs et de la
liste de violette espil boot
elle avait d'ailleurs proposé un
rapprochement à stéphane baly qui n'a
pas souhaité donner suite
un schéma quasi semblable à toulouse
mais cette fois
la candidate des partis de gauche nadia
pellefigue arrivé 3e retire carrément sa
candidature elle refuse de s'allier à la
liste des verts archipel citoyens
conduite par antoine maurice arrivé
second lors du premier tour les échanges
qui se sont tenues depuis l'issue du
premier tour elle me permet donc pas de
considérer que les conditions sont
aujourd'hui revenus
réunis pour un rassemblement de nos deux
listes que chacun porterai avec fierté
et enthousiasme
même si elle indique ne pas vouloir être
un obstacle au rassemblement à gauche
cette déclaration va profiter au maire
sortant et l'air à jean luc moudenc
arrivé en tête au premier tour
socialistes écologistes sont donc en
désaccord à lille et à toulouse mais à
paris en revanche n'est pas la même
histoire il n'y a pas encore de fumée
blanche mais on prépare le foyer j'ai
bon espoir que l'on top dès ce soir
oui les négociations vont bon train
david belliard le candidat e élevé est
confiant également et même si on achoppe
toujours sur des sujets de fond selon
les mots de son entourage est la fusion
devrait bien elle se tenir un soutien de
poids puisque le candidat écologiste à
récolter et 10,8 pour cent des voix au
premier tour et qui pourrait bien faire
la différence
pour anne hidalgo un choix s'inscrivant
dans la durée les écologistes font en
effet partie de la majorité de gauche à
l'hôtel de ville de paris depuis 2001 et
l'élection de bertrand delanoë a lyon
aussi on opte pour la sécurité après le
séisme provoqué par gérard collomb et
son alliance avec le candidat ait l'air
renault perd candidat de la gauche unie
à la métropole a confirmé qu'une
alliance avait été trouvé entre
l'ensemble de la gauche et les
écologistes
c'est fait nous allons nous présenter
ensemble pour le second tour derrière la
candidature de bruno bernard il y aura
la gauche unie la gauche rassemblée et
nous pourrons proposer aux habitants de
la métropole un vrai projet fondé sur
l'écologie et la justice sociale une
alliance qui devrait permettre aux
écologistes de réaliser le grand chelem
avec leur tandem grégory doucet à la
ville et bruno bernard à la métropole
pour marseille la situation est plus
complexe
mais là aussi l'enjeu pour le printemps
marseillais le parti de gauche arrivé en
tête était de parachever un accord avec
les écologistes afin de faire basculer
in gérées par la droite depuis plus de
25 ans vous l'aurez compris dans la
plupart des grandes villes l'alliance
entre verts et gauche et au centre des
débats
pour ce second tour des élections
municipales mais les égos de chacun ont
tendance à prédominer quitte à bafouer
idéologies politiques de leur parti aux
profits même leurs aînés et pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe est ce
qu écrivain ex-adjoint de manuel valls à
la mairie d'evry
bonsoir philippe pascot merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur les français
leur mac et de parler avec nous de la
question de ces alliances de manière un
petit peu global c'est le jeu cynique de
la politique
non c'est le jeu pourri de la politique
c'est l'arrière cuisine des politiques
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas été capable
de s'affirmer qui donc ici de se
regrouper plus ou moins en lâchant leurs
convictions parce que faut pas se faire
d'illusions quand on s'allie au 2e tour
au lhc conviction on travaille pour les
postes on travaille pas pour les
convictions alors justement ce n'est pas
de nature à augmenter encore plus la
défiance sein d'un électorat déjà voilà
pas toujours très en confiance avec la
classe politique on n'est plus dans le
cadre d'une défiance
on est dans le cadre d'une horreur je
dire les gens maintenant en ont marre
des politicards en ont marre de ces
tambouille de ses salades de ces gens
qui passent leur temps à négocier des
postes plutôt que des convictions il n'y
a plus aucune conviction dans les
élections
la preuve regardez avec combien de
pourcentage ces gens là sont élus il ya
des endroits où ils sont élus avec moins
de 1 électeur sur dix - de un électeur
sur dix c'est plus de la démocratie on a
envie de demander dans ces cas là vous
étiez aussi responsables politiques
proches des manuels real de manuel valls
pourquoi ça continue ça veut dire quoi à
clé les politiques n'entendent pas le
message que va leur adresser l'électorat
savez on dit qu'on dise il faut tous
comme griveaux et ça rend sourd donc il
est évident que les gens comprennent pas
il s'est toujours les mêmes on retrouve
les mêmes quand vous voyez que il ya un
type comme copé qui s'est encore
présenté à meaux et qui a été élu
plus les gens là ne sont plus à l'écouté
du peuple
ces gens là sont dehors ils parlent tous
d'un nouveau monde d'une nouvelle
politique mais il présente les vieux
nous les mêmes vieux cheval de bataille
alors que faudrait il faire selon vous
que ces gens là arrête
il ya un type qui nous a dit en mai 2010
est qu'il allait moraliser la vie
politique que les gens n'allaient pas
pouvoir faire des carrières politiques
on constate au fur et à mesure des
élections c'est encore les mêmes qui se
présentent les mêmes qui nous vendent
leurs salades qui commence à être franc
dates et les gens n'y croient plus les
gens ne vont plus voter et regarder sur
les municipales
les gens se sont tellement abstenus qu'
il ya plus que 0 carrément 0 1 %
d'abstention dans les urnes
les gens en ont marre ils vont même pu
voter et c'est ce que vol des politis à
vous le savez fini parce que c'est aussi
dû à cette crise du coronavirus en
france était une erreur vous faites
partie de ceux qui pensent que c'était
une erreur de le maintenir ce non
seulement c'était une erreur mais
c'était une folie vous faites les
élections le dimanche et le lundi vous
confiner les gens vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'il ya eu une petite
magouille là dedans
vous n'avez pas l'impression que quelque
part on est en train d'être complètement
dans distorsion vous avez le droit
d'être côte à côte dans les avions dans
les transports du rer c le matin pour
aller bosser et vous pouvez pas être à
moins d'un mètre cinquante dans les
restaurants et on va encore envoyer des
gens voter le 28 juin juste au moment où
ils partent en vacances et vous allez
voir que en septembre comme par hasard
on va re confiné à l'or lors du second
tour de la dernière élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron et marine le pen l'appel
au vote a été un grand débat pour faire
barrage on le sait ou rn certains de
gauche et de droite ont appelé à voter
mettront ça va être la même chose
pendant ces municipales comme c'est
souvent le cas
quelle est votre position là dessus
alors qu'on peut pas vous soupçonnés
d'être proches du rassemblement national
mais il n'y a pas un déni de démocratie
tout de même mais c'est pas qu'il ya des
lignes démocratie mais si ces gens là
n'allumez pas le feu ils seraient pas
obligées de l'éteindre
à chaque fois on nous faisant peur avec
le front national si ces gens-là été
bons dans les partis politiques qui le
représente
je vais vous dire les extrêmes
n'arriverait même pas au deuxième tour
parce que l'ensemble des gens qui votent
les extrêmes c'est pas des extrémistes
c'est des gens qui en ont marre qui ne
se reconnaissent plus dans aucun parti
politique et il se réfugie dans une
autre famille un peu plus un peu plus
extrémistes si ils étaient n'y ait pas
s'il a lui mais pas les incendies il
serait pas obligé de les éteindre
catastrophe mais en plus il faut que
vous sachiez que pour la plupart des
politiques ça les arrange que le front
national soit au deuxième tour ça les
arrange que les extrêmes soit au
deuxième tour parce que celui qui arrive
au deuxième tour il est aujourd'hui
quasiment sûre d'être élu mais faites
attention le peuple et pas si con ça
veut dire que beaucoup jouant le jeu non
pas du front national mais du
rassemblement national notamment à
commencer par souvent on l'accuse de
cela en tout cas le président de la
république lui même mais il n'en jouent
ils en abusent ils en abusent
parce que c'est pas un type qui vote qui
veut voter pour qui fit voter les gens
pour les convictions comme ça c'est des
gens qui travaillent qui magouille qui
font de la cuisine et aurier électorale
uniquement pour avoir des postes parce
que la soupe est bonne et qui veulent
garder la soupe
c'était différent quand vous étiez vous
aux affaires aux côtés de manuel valls
rougit pas que manuel valls à manu mais
je l'appelle dark vador maintenant je
suis là sans quelle raison pourquoi
parce qu'il est passé de l'autre côté du
miroir et je suis la seule personne qui
me soient battues physiquement deux fois
avec lui mais moi j'ai connu la
politique en 25 ans avec moi des gens
qui étaient peut-être entre guillemets
ou si des ripoux mais au moins il avait
un peu de classe aujourd'hui non
seulement c'est des ripoux mais c'est
des gens qui ont pu de classe je vais
vous dire une chose en politique
aujourd'hui
le mensonge est devenu la règle et la
vérité devenu l'exception c'est avec ça
que ces gens là ils nous regardent dans
les yeux et ils nous disent regardez je
suis bon regarder alors qu'ils ont rien
fait il ose dire qu'ils vont faire mieux
c'est une honte et c'est pour ça que les
gens ne vont plus voter et c'est pour ça
que les gens se détournent de la
politique mais comme c'est eux qui se
partagent le gâteau entre eux parce que
regarder sur les élections municipales
dans tous les endroits où il ya des
cadors dans tous les endroits où il ya
des responsables politiques de premier
plan
il n'ya jamais
un homme politique de premier plan qui
se présente contre lui ou contre elle
ils se sont partagé le gâteau ces braves
gens et ils se partagent les gâteaux sur
toute la france
et est-ce qu'il ya un seul parti
politique aujourd'hui qu'à dénoncer les
élections du 28 juin
aucun ils sont tous d'accord pour qu'on
le fasse parce que ça les arrange parce
qu'ils ont bien compris que moi y'a des
gens qui votent plus ils sont sûrs
d'être élu dans certains endroits et ils
ont fait leurs comptes
merci en tout cas philippe pascot
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir voilà
apportez votre code coup de colère ce
soir sur rtl france merci à vous phare
depuis ce matin de la prise en charge
complète du chômage partiel par l'état
ce dispositif a été mis en place au
début du confinement pour éviter des
licenciements massifs à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus que 85% de
cette indemnité qui seront pris en
charge par le pays
les entreprises doivent donc à présent
versé les 15 % restants à leurs salariés
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian de boissieu économistes vice
président du cercle des économistes
bonsoir christian de boissieu merci
lettre soit avec nous en direct sur rt
france donc désormais l'état n'assure
plus la prise en charge complète du
chômage partiel
concrètement ça veut dire quoi et
surtout concrètement qu'elles vont en
être les conséquences d'un concrètement
ça veut dire que les entreprises montant
en régime dans ce dispositif et est
progressivement la part payée par l'état
va se réduire la part payée par les
entreprises veulent monter donc on a une
sortie en sifflet de ce dispositif alors
la sorte qui va être plus lente pour les
secteurs qui sont pas des consignes et
aujourd'hui je pense hôtels restaurants
et un certain nombre de secteurs touchés
que les autres les conséquences vous
m'interrogez sur les conséquences ça
veut dire que tu rends sortant
progressivement jeudi lien
progressivement du régime du chômage
partiel en augmentant ce qui est
inévitable parce que le l'état peut pas
continuer à l'appuyer 100% comme ça
pendant des mois on augmenta la part des
entreprises
ça veut dire à mon avis que dans
certains cas le chômage partiel va
laisser la place au chômage tout court
c'est à dire qui il va y avoir
- dans bausch par les entreprises il
peut y avoir même dans certains cas des
lycées et licenciements secs donc moi je
suis assez pessimiste sur l'évolution du
chômage en 30 dans les mois qui viennent
il voit pas comment ça a été extrêmement
difficile d'endiguer la montée toujours
à l'état on le rappelle on continue
quand même de prendre en charge 80 5%
c'est quand même beaucoup quelle aurait
été la meilleure solution selon non non
je suis pas en train de vous dire que
c'est pas bon c'est l'état et l'unedic
qui prennent en charge
mais progressivement leurs charges et
damman lâchage l'égard des entreprises
va augmenter on ne peut pas ne pas
rester des trimestre comme ça dans le
chômage partiel donc c'est inévitable
mais je pense que dans le même temps il
faut faire un effort majeur pour essayer
de de contenir on n'empêchera pas la
montée du chômage mais essayer de la
contenir un peu alors ça veut dire ça
veut dire d'abord à mon avis c'est des
problèmes de financement lutter contre
les faillites qui interviendront dans le
tissu des tpe des toutes petites
entreprises et des pme
bon là il va ya des faillites mais aussi
dans le nord et je vous donne un exemple
concret l'état a promis de en quelque
sorte pour plus de 300 milliards d'euros
de crédits bancaires garantis par l'état
justement à 90 % maximum 90 % sur le
terrain et c'est 300 milliards d'euros
de crédits bancaires ils sont encore là
il ya une proportion il n'y a même pas
une pas 150 milliards et d'accorder donc
il faut accélérer l'accès des pme à des
financements qui leur permet de survivre
et en réduisant les faillites
d'entreprises on va réduire aussi on n'a
pas empêché va réduire la montée du
chômage
et puis il faut réfléchir au problème du
chômage des jeunes parce que la rentrée
va arriver il allait avoir 700 mille
jeunes diplômés pas diplômés qui vont se
présenter qu'est ce qu'on va qu'est ce
qu'on leur propose concrètement qu'est
ce qu'on va leur proposer donc là on a
besoin aussi sans doute le coup de pouce
de l'état prime à l'embauché allègements
de charges
enfin on connaît déjà le dispositif ça
coûte de l'argent d'un sens où on en est
la dérive des dérives des finances
publiques est telle que ça coûtera de
l'argent en plus mais je répète
enfin dans un océan de béton smic est
tristan boissieu quand on parle de
chômage partiel on parle malheureusement
aussi parfois de fraudes c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est la cgt 25 % des
entreprises ayant bénéficié du chômage
partiel avait en réalité fraude et
faisons ce qui tout de même travailler
leurs salariés
des chiffres difficiles à confirmer mais
enfin il n'empêche que bruno le maire a
réagi nous savons qu'il ya eu des abus
sur l'utilisation du chômage partiel il
y aura des sanctions
quelle est votre réaction le système
n'est pas parfait mais voilà que faut-il
faire écouter le système n'est pas
parfait il ya des effets d'aubaine il ya
des entreprises comment profiter plus
que de mesure et en dehors de la
légalité pour que là je pense
il faudra des il faut des contrôles et
des sanctions ceci dit je pense qu'on a
quand même globalement une raison de
mettre en place un régime de chômage
partiel qui est sans doute plus généreux
qui existait en europe au cours des deux
mois de confinement bon parce que
pourquoi on a une raison parce que si on
avait passé sa le chômage aurait aurait
monté beaucoup plus vite alors là à
travers ce dispositif qui va être
supprimé en douceur mais en profondeur
on glisse on lis un peu dans le temps la
montée qu'il paraît inévitable du
chômage d'ici la fin de l'année de
l'ivac on lisse mais ceci dit ça des
conséquences regarder les pannes qui
s'est accumulée qui a été acculé par les
36 points rapidement
elle va se transformer en consommation
nick ancien de la confiance et la
confiance ou la défense ça va dépendre
de du marché du travail
si comme je le crains le chômage
continue continûment augmente
ici la fin de l'année 2020 d'aller voir
que les français ils vont continuer à
épargner ils vont au moins consommer
donc ces sujets c'est le tuer pour moi
le coeur de la reprise en france comme
nous doter le coeur de la reprise et la
situation du marché du travail
ma dernière question aujourd'hui vous
parler des hôtels par exemple qui
peuvent rouvrir
ils ont d'ailleurs jamais le droit avait
sauvé le droit de travailler
certains peut-être préfère rester fermés
ou des restaurants qui ne gagnerait pas
assez d'argent avec les règles qui sont
difficiles à tenir les règles de
restriction
que faire renforcer les contrôles sur ce
type d'entreprise qui préfèrent utiliser
le chômage partiel plutôt que de
travailler à perte ou ou sans gagner
d'argent
ben s'il ya des abus oui je suis
d'accord je reviens sur le contrôle et
sanction en même temps je veux dire avec
le régime des tirages des terrasses qui
s'ouvre ils vont être ouvertes dans les
régions et départements qui reste oranje
dans dans la région ile de france
bon ça veut dire que les restaurants
vont faire qu'une partie de leur chiffre
d'affaires alors j'imagine que certains
d'entre eux font un calcul où on ouvre
complètement ce qui est le cas dans les
zones vertes
ils doivent ouvrir complètement à partir
de demain ou alors on ose partiellement
en créant des terrasses en élargissant
des terrasses et hélas il faut voir ce
que ça rapporte qu'aucun temps et puis
il faut se remettre au boulot c'est à
dire que tu frappes et quand on écoute
aujourd'hui les restaurateurs il vous
explique quand même que ça fait deux
mois qu'ils ont fermé ben il faut un peu
de temps donc être non pas ils vont pas
se remettre à fonctionner tous à partir
de demain où quelques jours pour
relancer la machine
merci beaucoup question de boissieu
économistes vice président du cercle des
économistes d'avoir été avec nous
nouveau coup de frein sur le marché
automobile français en mai une chute de
plus de 50% de nouvelles
immatriculations pour le mois dernier
11e forte baisse mensuelle d'affilée
après un recul de 72% mars et de près de
90 % en avril et prévision annuelle du
secteur sont comprises entre moins 20 et
moins 30% c'est aujourd'hui que les
primes à la conversion annoncée la
semaine dernière par emmanuel macron
entre en vigueur et salariés de renault
plus que jamais inquiet pour leur poste
la marque au losange prévoit un plan
d'économies de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros sur trois ans avec 4600
suppressions d'emplois en france et plus
de 10000 hors de l'hexagone
hier jean dominique senard président de
l'entreprise a déclaré que la fonderie
de bretagne n'avait pas vocation à
rester dans le groupe automobile le
constructeur avait pourtant promis le
contraire il y a deux jours lors de la
fermeture de choisy-le-roi mai
célèbre site morbihannais subi les
évolutions écologique ce les pièces en
acier pour la fabrication de moteurs
sont dépassés par l'arrivée du tout
électrique
écoutez l'analyse de jean marc sylvestre
[Applaudissements]
ça va régler le problème de la
trésorerie mais ça ne l'a sans doute pas
régler le problème de la stratégie il
est fondé sur l'électrique vous savez
l'électrique bas tout le monde adore le
discours politique les écolos mais ça va
quand même être long et s'écoute pour
trois raisons la première il faut se
rendre à l'évidence les automobilistes
ne se précipitent pas sur la voiture
électrique on va d'ailleurs voir là avec
les primes si l'on achète vraiment ou
pas parce qu'il ya un problème
d'autonomie maximum 150 200 km alors
c'est bien pour la ville mais il faut
des bornes
il n'y a pas beaucoup de bornes de
recharge la recharge et l'on s'est pas
commode électrique c'est pas au point
encore et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que la voiture n était qu à besoin de
batterie la batterie et les seuls
fournisseurs de batteries aujourd'hui ce
sont les chinois alors on va se mettre
pieds et poings liés avec les chinois à
cause des batteries et puis aussi la
voiture électrique elle a besoin de
digital beaucoup de digital et que le
digital est bien dit il est
principalement américains alors on peut
bâtir on peut bâtir toutes les
stratégies franco française que l'on
veut la voiture électrique aura du mal à
être française elle sera beaucoup plus
chinoise est beaucoup plus américaines
que françaises si ça qu'il faut dont il
faut prendre conscience ça pose quand
même un énorme problème d'autonomie
j'allais même dire de souveraineté dans
ces conditions bas on voit mal quelle
peut être la stratégie de renault pour
les dix prochaines années
elle sera compliqué et des syndicats ont
raison de s'en inquiéter
m lle en seine saint denis un
rassemblement avait lieu cet après midi
en soutien gabriel djordjevic ce
collégien de 14 ans interpellé par les
forces de l'ordre dans la nuit du 25 au
26 mai sa famille qui l'a retrouvé à
l'hôpital avec de nombreux hématomes
accusé la police de l'avoir violenté les
précisions de notre reporter et la
fameuse où ils étaient une cinquantaine
de personnes rassemblées ici devant la
mairie de bondy pour soutenir gabriel un
adolescent de 14 ans interpellés entre
la nuit du 25 au 26 mai alors qu'il
tentait de voler un scooter sa famille
l'a récupéré à l'hôpital jean verdier
très grièvement blessé à l'oeil avec un
traumatisme crânien et trois dents
cassées parmi les participants
aujourd'hui aussi bien les membres de la
famille de l'adolescent que des
personnalités politiques qui sont venus
ici exprimer leur indignation face à ce
qu'ils considèrent comme des violences
policières que rien ne justifie je
propose de les écouter on a encore sous
le choc
ça peut arriver aujourd'hui à d autres
temps froid aussi
stop à la violence
c'est une mici merci tous autant que
vous êtes ici il ya quelque chose de
très grave qui se passe le voilà dans
notre police qui est dangereuse
maintenant pour les jeunes j'imagine que
pour eux la plus là pour la plupart ça
doit être difficile de sortir de chez
soi et la peur qui doit être en eux la
peur pour les familles et voilà donc
c'était important d'être là en soutien à
gabriel de mât pour à ça traoré la
mémoire d'adama et pour la justice aussi
on a besoin de justice la famille de
l'adolescent a déposé plainte auprès de
la police des polices l'igpn
et puis parmi les personnes qui
participaient au rassemblement
plusieurs d'entre elles ont prévu de se
rassembler ce mardi pour une autre
victime de violences policières adama
traoré décédé lors d'une interpellation
en 2016 et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point complet sur l'actualité ce sera
dans quelques minutes pour un journal
classique bon courage à tous et à tout à
l'heure
nous
[Musique]
l'afrique qui compte 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais ne
sont pas encore au nouveau où se trouve
par exemple les roms pour les états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça l'est
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'elle
venait de sortir d'une d'une épidémie à
ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
que si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour nous
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui la gauche peut extraire tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
et
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la fontaine de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté 14 trop fine il ya un
tournant et on refera met à vivre mais
dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
simple jamais là d'une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques et sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon adaptation
dans la crise du coc vite 19
c'est toute une chaîne décisionnelle
médicales administratives et politiques
irresponsables peluche est alors que l'
oms recommandait le port du masque par
les populations la parole publique a
longtemps menti sur sa nécessité pour ne
pas avouer la triste absence du stock
clip
la décision de confinement s'imposait
compte-tenu du manque de matériel
permettant d'autres solutions mais en
freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise les connaissent l'état ne
pourra plus être l'état providence que
nous avons que khurram aura été
cimetière de certaines espérances en
pensant que le progrès faisait de nous
des hommes dieu et que les technocrates
avec les du monde demain les
conséquences de la crise oblige à
repenser nos modèles la découverte du
télétravail l'intérêt de consommer des
produits locaux besoin de solidarité
vont faire évoluer une population qui a
découvert qu'elle était mortel
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
alors ce qui si seul un père dit
d'interdire
[Musique]
l'amérique qui saura après la crise
sanitaire des crises sociales pillage
leur couvre feu dans plusieurs dizaines
de villes la nuit dernière et garde
nationale déployé une semaine de
violences à la suite de la mort de
l'afro américain john floyd lors d'une
intervention policière
l'audience du policier incriminé
reporter le chef de l'onu appelle à
enquêter sur ces violences policières
retour en classe des lycéens fin de la
règle des 100 km réouverture des
restaurants en zone verte et des
terrasses en zone orange
j - avant la deuxième étape du
déconfinement france est également
demain midi que l'application
controversée stuff kobe tu dois être
disponible le break 6 est à nouveau au
coeur des pourparlers entre l'union
européenne et londres une semaine
décisive pour tenter de trouver un
accord commercial donc
johnson pas personnellement ces
discussions-là négociateur européen
barnier est lui aussi souligné dans une
interview au journal britannique the
times que le temps pressait
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france une semaine après
la mort de john of floyd un afro
américain décédé au cours d'une
interpellation policière
plusieurs manifestations en virée aux
émeutes aux états unis pour une sixième
nuit de violences scènes de pillage et
d'affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre couvre-feu dans une quarantaine
de villes du pays
retour sur les émeutes en images avec
claire nico la maison blanche plongé
dans le noir est attaquée par des
manifestants
le symbole du pouvoir américain a
violemment été pris à partie cette nuit
à washington donald trump a même été mis
à l'abri quelques heures dans un bunker
souterrain une réponse probable des
manifestants aux propos tenus samedi par
le président américain
il avait menacé les émeutiers si
l'approché de la maison blanche il
n'hésiterait pas à lâcher je cite ces
chiens les plus méchants et à utiliser
les armes les plus inquiétantes des
menaces loin de calmer les
protestataires de nombreux pillages et
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
ont été observées cette nuit dans le
reste du pays
et ce malgré le couvre-feu imposé dans
plusieurs grandes villes américaines
treize mille soldats sont actuellement
mobilisées et puis des scènes
quotidiennes sur réel
comme hier à minneapolis
un camion citerne a forcé le passage
fonçant dans les manifestants
heureusement il n'y aura aucun blessé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à santa monica en californie les forces
de l'ordre ont arrêté plusieurs
manifestants des arrestations
souvent sans distinction des métiers
mais aussi de simples civils
la khl à aix matters la vie des noirs
compte c'est ce qu'on a encore une fois
martelé les foules de protestataires
les afro américains ne représentent que
13% de la population des états unis ils
ont pourtant trois fois plus de chances
de se faire arrêter par la police
et ça dure depuis bien trop longtemps et
il faut y mettre fin
il y en a assez nous sommes des êtres
humains nous sommes tous pareils nous
devons être traités de la même manière
pas pour une différence de couleur de
classe de race ou de croyances nous
sommes des personnes et nous de vous
être traités de la même manière je suis
fatigué c'est un point de basculement je
l'espère c'est quelque chose qui s'est
produit sur plusieurs années mais la
mort de jack floyd a je pense accentuer
la rage la colère que ressentent les
noirs
je suppose que le simple fait de voir le
policier assassiné sur son cou avec son
genou sur la nuque
pendant huit minutes c'était un point de
basculement extrême alors j'espère que
le changement viendra une confrontation
entre policiers et manifestants qui ne
faiblit pourtant pas depuis
l'arrestation du policier accusé du
meurtre de john floyd en six jours plus
de 4000 personnes ont été arrêtées aux
états unis mais alors le secrétaire
général de l'onu antonio guterres s
appelle lui à enquêter sur les violences
policières discours opposé du côté de
donald trump le président américain
demande au gouverneur de chaque étage
aussi d'user de tactique agressive
contre les manifestants selon cnn avant
d'ajouter vous devez dominé sinon vous
aurez l'air de cons vous devez arrêter
les gens et les poursuivre en justice
fin de citation et la mobilisation
dépasse désormais les frontières
américaines plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont ainsi défilé hier à
londres berlin ou encore toronto retour
en images sur ces rassemblements
nous voyons depuis des centaines
d'années que les noirs et les gens de
couleur sont absolument maltraités et
tués dans les rues et ça ne fait
qu'empirer
nous en avons assez et s'ils ne veulent
pas écouter l'encrier de plus en plus
fort et nous n'allons pas arrêter tant
que quelque chose ne sera pas fait nous
en avons assez
ces gens en ont assez les temps de faire
quelques changements
c'est galère
et ils vont me tuer ils vont me tuer je
ne peux pas respirer
je ne peux pas respirer s'il vous plaît
monsieur s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je ne peux pas respirer
je promets que les futurs bébés noirs ne
mourront pas parce que je n'en ai pas
fait assez
parce que j'ai passé plus de temps à
pleurer à me plaindre et à poster que je
n'ai fait de vraies actions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
en tête
[Musique]
et le maire de new york à l'instant
vient d'annoncer le couvre feu dans la
ville
pour olivier py ton avocat au barreau de
washington ces notes représente une
convergence des luttes de tous les
américains
mais face à une conjonction des révoltes
par la peur c'est par la peur et la
précarité et la peur d'une part parce
que les gens se disent les violences
policières peuvent me touche et moi je
sois un homme que je sois une femme je
sois blanc que je sois noir je peux me
faire à un moment je peux me retrouver
dans la situation d'un georges floyd et
en nourrir je pense que les gens en ont
marre effectivement de cette forme
d'impunité policière qui dépasse le
cadre du racisme parce que le racisme il
va falloir le prouver et celle enquête
qui déterminera si derek sherwin qui est
quand même qui en est déjà à dix huit
blâme
donc c'est un personnage tout à fait
particulier de la police de mes abdos
minneapolis si il a agi parce que son
interlocuteur était noir sont suspects
étaient noirs ou parce qu'il l'aurait
fait avec d'autres
justin trudeau exclu aujourd'hui toute
participation de la russie au prochain
sommet du g7 le premier ministre
canadien rejette donc la proposition
faite par le président américain
d'inviter d'autres pays à se joindre au
rendez vous samedi 2-1 trump a souhaité
élargir la réunion en incluant la russie
la corée du sud l'inde et l'australie
est là au prochain g7 pour cause de
pandémie le sommet reporté en automne et
sans la chine le rendez vous devait se
tenir ce mois ci aux états unis moscou
estime pour leur manquait d'informations
sur le contenu de cette réunion pour
accepter d'y participer on écoute le
porte parole du kremlin
il a été question de l'invitation de la
russie et d'autres pays au sommet du g7
ce qui soulève de nouvelles questions en
quelle qualité avec quels agendas
quelle liste de participants vous savez
que le président poutine est un partisan
du dialogue mais dans ce cas pour que
nous réagissions à une telle initiative
nous avons besoin d'informations
supplémentaires que nous nous possédons
malheureusement pas pour le moment
en général vous savez qu'il existe un
format efficace d'actualité et utile
pour le dialogue international
c'est le g20 qui permet aux pays
concernés les principales économies
mondiales d'examiner les questions les
plus actuelles
mais alors que la phase 2 du
déconfinement est lancé ce mardi le
nombre de personnes en réanimation en
france continuent de baisser selon les
chiffres de la direction générale de la
santé oms compte 31 nouveaux décès à
l'hôpital en 24 heures au total 28 mille
huit cent trente trois personnes sont
décédées depuis le début de l'épidémie
une nouvelle annonce du ministère de la
santé les ehpad pourront rouvrir les
visites à plus de deux personnes à la
fois et aux mineurs dès vendredi
quant aux personnes sortis guéris
l'hôpital sont au nombre de 68 1355 la
phase 2 du déconfinement une étape
décisive pour la reprise de l'économie
et de la vie sociale des français preuve
de la reprise
une grande partie des établissements
scolaires ouvriront leurs portes demain
un deuxième palier qui ne sera pas
uniforme sur tout le territoire mode
d'emploi avec théo point bas c'était
attendu par de nombreux français
les cafés bars et restaurants sont enfin
autorisés à rouvrir complètement en zone
verte dès demain et partiellement en
ile-de-france en guyane et à mayotte
dans ces trois territoires seuls les
terrasses pourront accueillir des
clients un dispositif qui satisfait ce
restaurateur parisien
je pense que oui ça va un peu nous aider
justement avec la vente à emporter si on
arrive à gérer les deux alors là tu
erasmus la vente à emporter ça nous aide
parce que des lacets une visibilité le
fait d'être ouvert ça permet de montrer
qu'on existe encore dans beaucoup de
bars et de restaurants à paris il ya des
habitués et les habitués là on a vu
depuis un mois et ça va continuer
vraiment nous soutenir donc ils seront
d'un donc je pense qu'en fait vu le peu
de tables qu'on aura en terrasse on sera
toujours plein une disparité qui
s'appliquera aussi aux hébergements
touristiques qui rouvriront dès le 2
juin en zone verte mais pas avant le 22
du mois en zone orange même différence
pour les piscines salles de sport parc
de loisirs salle de spectacle et pour
les théâtres
autre bonne nouvelle pour le tourisme
plages lacs et musées seront dans leur
ensemble accessible au public dès demain
pour les professionnels du secteur
l'heure est au soulagement même si cette
réouverture dans des conditions
sanitaires strictes chamboule de
nombreux établissements donc de ce côté
là c'est la partie sommes donc les gens
prendre en compte par cette porte et
sortiront par celle ci donc il n'ya pas
de croisement de personnes et en plus on
valeur ajoutée des distributeurs de
savon à chaque que nos champions impôts
est également à l'intérieur des douches
par ailleurs les déplacements des
français ne seront plus limités
la barrière des 100 km et enlever les
déplacements entre métropole et outre
mer reste toutefois conditionnée à des
motifs impérieux
enfin les déplacements hors de france
sont pour l'instant impossible
prochain étape du déconfinement le 22
juin et fin depuis ce matin de la prise
en charge complète du chômage partiel
par l'état ce dispositif a été mis en
place au début de confinement pour
éviter des licenciements massifs
à partir d'aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus
que 85% de cette indemnité qui seront
pris en charge par le pays
les entreprises doivent à présent versé
les 15 % traitant restant alors salariés
et pour christian de boissieu économise
vice président du cercle des économistes
nous sommes qu'au début de cette crise
économique en france n'a concrètement ça
veut dire que les entreprises montant en
régime dans ce dispositif et est
progressivement la part payée par l'état
va se réduire la part payée par les
entreprises vont augmenter donc on a
même sortie en sifflet de ce dispositif
alors la sortie va être plus lente pour
les secteurs pense hôtels restaurants et
la certain nombre de secteurs plus
touchés que les autres les conséquences
vous m'interrogez sur les conséquences
ça veut dire que en sortant
progressivement jeudi a progressivement
du régime du chômage partiel en
augmentant ce qui est inévitable parce
que l'état peut pas continuer à
l'appeler 100% comme ça pendant des mois
on augmenta la part des entreprises
ça veut dire à mon avis que dans
certains cas le chômage partiel va
laisser la place au chômage tout court
d'ailleurs qu' il va y avoir moins dans
bausch par les entreprises et peut y
avoir même dans certains cas des
licenciements secs donc moi je suis
assez pessimiste sur l'évolution du
chômage en 30 dans les mois qui viennent
a été extrêmement difficile d'endiguer
la montée du chômage et dans le reste de
l'actualité à bondy en seine-saint-denis
un rassemblement avait lieu cet après
midi en soutien à gabriel djordjevic ce
collégien de 14 ans interpellé par les
forces de l'ordre dans la nuit du 25 au
26 mai sa famille qui l'a retrouvé à
l'hôpital avec de nombreux hématomes
accusé la police de l'avoir violenté les
précisions de notre reporter et la faa
montceau ils étaient une cinquantaine de
personnes rassemblées ici devant la
mairie de bondy pour soutenir gabriel un
adolescent de 14 ans interpellés entre
la nuit du 25 au 26 mai alors qu'il
tentait de voler un scooter sa famille
l'a récupéré à l'hôpital jean verdier
très grièvement blessé à l'oeil avec un
traumatisme crânien et trois dents
cassées parmi les participants
aujourd'hui aussi bien les membres de la
famille de l'adolescent que des
personnalités politiques qui sont venus
ici exprimer leur indignation face à ce
qu'ils considèrent comme des violences
policières que rien ne justifie je
propose de les écouter on encore sous le
choc
ça peut arriver aujourd'hui à des hôtes
en france y est
stop à la violence c'est notre mission
merci tous autant que vous êtes ici il
ya quelque chose de très grave qui se
passe voilà dans notre police qui est
dangereuse maintenant pour les jeunes
j'imagine que pour eux la plupart ont
pour la plupart ça doit être difficile
de sortir de chez soi et la peur qui
doit être en eux la peur pour les
familles et voilà donc c'était important
d'être là en soutien à gabriel de mât
pour as à traoré la mémoire damas et
pour la justice aussi on a besoin de
justice la famille de l'adolescent a
déposé plainte auprès de la police des
polices l'igpn
et puis parmi les personnes qui
participaient au rassemblement
plusieurs d'entre elles ont prévu de se
rassembler ce mardi pour une autre
victime de violences policières adama
traoré décédé lors d'une interpellation
en 2016 en russie plus de 9000
contamination ans kobe de 19 enregistrée
hier le pays a dépassé le seuil des 400
mille cas de coronavirus malgré cela le
taux de mortalité reste faible 140 mort
hier du côté de moscou
très prudent retour à la normale depuis
ce matin ou plusieurs restrictions ont
été levées
et ce alors que velimir poutine s'est
entretenu aujourd'hui avec le groupe de
travail chargé de la réforme
constitutionnelle
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
claireaux le début du printemps a été
compliqué pour le kremlin report des
célébrations du 9 mai qui venaient
commémorer les 75 ans de la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale
report de ce scrutin sur la réforme
constitutionnelle les choses semblent
rentrer dans l'ordre
on l'a appris la semaine dernière la
grande parade militaire du 9 mai a été
décalée au 24 juin concernant cette
grande consultation populaire sur les
amendements constitutionnels
la date du 24 juin a elle aussi été
soumises dans un premier temps à vladmir
poutine
mais le président estimé qu'un minimum
de 30 jours étaient requis pour préparer
le vôtre en conséquence c'est donc la
date du 1er juillet qui a été retenu
écouter
je compte tenu de la tendance à
l'amélioration de la situation sanitaire
et épidémiologique
à mon avis la date optimale pour le vote
sur les amendements constitutionnels
serait le 1er juillet projet mega games
si vous venez chiner sur la base de la
discussion d'aujourd'hui et conformément
à ce que vous avez dit est proposé il
nous organiserons le vote sur les
amendements à la constitution de la
fédération de russie le 1er juillet 2020
c'est dans son discours annuel devant
l'assemblée fédérale de russie en tout
début d'année que vladimir poutine avait
suggéré plusieurs pistes afin de
modifier la constitution
après un parcours parlementaire
rondement mené le projet de loi a été
finalisée et la date du 22 avril a été
arrêté pour cette grande consultation
populaire
voulue par le président russe un texte
qui s'il est validé par ce scrutin donne
la possibilité à vladimir poutine
d'effectuer deux mandats supplémentaires
à partir de 2024
mais voilà le coronavirus sa venue
bouleverser le calendrier et le reflux
progressif de la pandémie en russie
permet maintenant au kremlin d'essayer
de rattraper le temps perdu et les
mesures sanitaires s'assouplissent dans
plusieurs pays également résultat de
nombreux lieux rouvrent leurs portes le
grand bazar à istanbul le colisée à rome
les centres commerciaux à tokyo tour
d'horizon en images
où
demandé de mentir le tas c'est un
sentiment d'excitation un sentiment de
grande excitation
nous avons l'impression que ce monument
historique nous appartient mais les
touristes manque
[Musique]
nous avons dû procéder à des changements
on a déplacé les bureaux pour qu'ils
soient dans une configuration différente
de celle à laquelle les enfants étaient
habitués avant de revenir aujourd'hui
nous avons également été très conscients
de la nécessité de garder les choses
aussi normal et cohérente que possible
le retour à l'école devrait être une
expérience vraiment positif pour eux
[Musique]
il
elle semaine cruciale pour le royaume
uni les négociations sur le break sites
ont repris aujourd'hui avec un seul
objectif trouver un accord commercial
avec l'union européenne
les précisions de valentin carpentier si
tout tourne autour de la crise sanitaire
du coc vie de 19 depuis maintenant
quatre mois
michel barnier lui n'a pas cessé de
chercher des solutions aux désaccords
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne sur le bric site le divorce
acté depuis le 31 janvier dernier
les deux parties doivent désormais se
mettre d'accord sur les nouvelles
relations surtout commerciale et le chef
des négociations sur le bric site pour
l'union européenne n'est pas très
optimiste le royaume uni a fait trois
pas en arrière par rapport aux
engagements pris à l'origine nous nous
souvenons très bien du texte que nous
avons négocié avec boris johnson et nous
voulons simplement qu'ils soient
respectées à la lettre
sinon il n'y aura pas d'accord des mots
durs quelques semaines après une période
de négociation à la mi mai marquée par
l'absence totale d'avancé si le temps
presse
une prolongation de la période de
transition qui doit s'achever à la fin
de l'année peut tout de même être
demandée avant le 1er juillet prochain
problème les deux parties campent sur
leurs positions
bruxelles souhaite un level playing
field soit un accord large avec des
garanties afin d'éviter une dérégulation
de l'économie britannique à son
détriment
de son côté londres demandent un accord
de libre-échange classique pour pouvoir
préserver son autonomie
une véritable impasse qui commence à
agacer les deux camps
l'union européenne veut essentiellement
que nous obéissons aux règles de son
club même si nous n'en sommes plus
membres et elle veut le même accès à nos
zones de pêche que celui dont elle
bénéficie actuellement tout en limitant
notre accès à ces marchés il reste
difficile de parvenir à un accord
mutuellement bénéfique tant que l'union
européenne maintient une telle approche
idéologique
à l'exception de ces quelques ouvertures
modeste aucun progrès n'a été possible
sur les autres sujets les plus
difficiles
le royaume uni n'a pas engagé de vraies
discussions sur la question du level
pile quoi qu'il en dise sans un cadre
clair et efficace de level paine field
sans un accord équilibré sur la pêche
il n'y aura pas qu'il ne pourra pas y
avoir d'accord sur notre partenariat
économique et commercial
l'espoir subsiste quand même londres et
bruxelles ont au moins une envie commune
éviter à tout prix le no deal qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'année si aucun accord
n'est trouvé dans ce cas là ce sera à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce de
fixer les règles
reste à voir lequel des deux camps sera
prêt à faire des concessions pour éviter
un désastre économique
pour claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales l'union
européenne à fort intérêt que le royaume
uni demandent un allongement du délai
des négociations mais malgré tout il est
fort possible que tout cela aboutisse à
un o'neal et dans le fond depuis le
début de l'année l'union européenne
considère que cet accord sera difficile
à négocier et la tradition de l'union
européenne c'est de négocier dans les
détails ces négociations qui durent
longtemps et d'opinion l'union
européenne c'est qu' il serait
préférable que le royaume uni
grande-bretagne demande avant le 30 juin
date qui est inscrite en dans la corde
de de départ et bien qu avant le 30 juin
les britanniques demandent une deuxième
année de transition c'est prévu dans
l'accord qu'ils seraient l'année 2020
terrasse qui donne à tout le temps de
négocier tranquillement un accord
équilibré
logiquement il est tout à fait probable
que l'on arrive à un odile le 31
décembre prochain et par conséquent il
faut en tout état de cause si préparer
parce que cette situation sera
dommageable pour toutes les économies
celle de l'union européenne comme
l'économie britannique
le co fondateur de wikileaks julian
assange est toujours incarcéré dans la
prison de belmarsh une audience
administratives via une liaison vidéo
depuis la prison devait se tenir
aujourd'hui dans son affaire
d'extradition à la cour de westminster
une audience à laquelle il n'a pu
assister en raison de problèmes
respiratoires selon ses avocats
vulnérable aux convives 19 un groupe de
manifestants s'est rassemblé devant le
tribunal pour demander sa libération
c'est une préoccupation majeure au
milieu de la pandémie de co vide quand
vous savez que les prisons sont une
boîte de pétri pour la propagation de la
maladie
c'est une situation extrêmement
préoccupante pour un homme qui a déjà
été affaiblie par sept ans à l'ambassade
de l'équateur
il a des maladies pulmonaires chroniques
qui ne sont pas en sa faveur en ces
temps difficiles où nous devons tous
prendre soin de notre santé
nous sommes donc très préoccupé par lui
et les preuves qu'il vit
le fondateur de wikileaks un innocent en
détention provisoire à la prison de
haute sécurité
c'est bouleversant
nous nous attendions tous à savoir ce
que sera le nouveau tribunal points la
deuxième parce que les positions
d'extradition de julian assange
mais malheureusement la juge a déclaré
qu'il n'avait toujours pas de
confirmation quant à l'endroit où la
deuxième partie des audiences d'assange
auront lieu à une nouvelle information à
l'instant dans la sphère john floyd aux
etats unis une autopsie indépendante
menée sur le corps de cet afro américain
décédé au cours d'une interpellation
policière conclut qu'il est mort
asphyxié information révélée par son
avocat et c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain point
complet sur l'actualité demain matin 7
heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck ça que ça
veut dire
facile à lire ça si la comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout mon jeu de